GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I WANT TO
CALL I WANT TO CALL ORDER THE
FIRST INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
TECHNOLOGY AND THE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
WORKFORCE. TODAY'S TOPIC IS
AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY AN
OVERVIEW S. TODAY'S TOPIC TITLE
SUGGESTS WE ARE HERE TODAY TO
GET A BROAD OVERVIEW ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF AG TECHNOLOGY. ON
OUR AGRICULTURE WORKFORCE I WANT
TO FIRST WELCOME AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC
FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MEMBERS THAT
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY BUT ARE
WATCHING AND LISTENING REMOTELY
. I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PORTRAITS OF PARTICIPANTS HERE
TODAY FURTHER FURTHER TIME AND
FOR HELPING US BETTER.
UNDERSTAND HOW AG TECHNOLOGY
WILL CONTINUE TO PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
WORKFORCE AND AGRICULTURAL
OVERALL. BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY I
NEED TO SHARE WHAT OUR PROCESS
IS GOING TO BE FOR THE REST OF
THE OF THE HEARING. I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE SAFE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THEREFORE WE ARE. ARE ONLY
ALLOWING A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
PERSON. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRED
THAT MASS BE WORN AT ALL TIMES
WHEN NOT SPEAKING AND THAT
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM MAINTAIN
PHYSICAL DISTANCE. IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE ALSO HAVE SEVERAL
OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
TODAY. IF ANY IF ANYONE FROM THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WHEN WE CALL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE END OF
THE HEARING. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO PROVIDE COMMENTS
BY USING. OUR MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICES. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
REQUESTING TO SPEAK WILL ONLY BE
ALLOWED ONE MINUTE PER PERSON SO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF
. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER
FOR THE HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. IF YOU'RE WATCHING ONLINE
OR ON YOUR TV YOU CAN ALSO FIND
FIND IT DISPLAYED ON YOUR SCREEN
. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THAT INCLUDES ME MUTINEER
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICES YOU CAN ALSO CALL
MY OFFICE AT. 916-319-2013 TO
LEAVE A COMMENT. WE WILL ALSO
ACCEPT WRITTEN TESTIMONIES VIA
EMAIL. TWO ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOT BE UP WITH WHAT AT S.
M. DOT CA DOT GOP. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE WILL. IMPLEMENT
THESE PRACTICES THAT CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND A SAFER MATTER. I WANT TO
OPEN BY SAYING AGRICULTURE
CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA. OVER HERE OVER A
THIRD OF THE COUNTRY'S
VEGETABLES AND TWO THIRDS OF THE
COUNTRY'S FRUITS AND THAT'S ARE
GROWING A CALIFORNIA.
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY THAT GENERATES
AT LEAST ONE BILLION IN RELATED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES. CALIFORNIA
ALSO LEADS IN THE NET IN THE
NATION TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS
. OUR STATE HAS A CRITICAL ECO
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT CUTTING EDGE
DEVELOPMENTS IN THIS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING AGTECH SECTOR.
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO THE HOME OF
THE NATION'S TOP AGRICULTURAL
SCIENCE UNIVERSITIES AND ELEVEN
TIER RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES THAT
CONTINUE TO MAKE DISCOVERIES AND
EVERYTHING FROM SEED BREEDING TO
BIO FUEL ALTERNATIVES. TODAY'S
ACT AGRICULTURE CONTINUES TO
INTEGRATE NEW TECHNOLOGIES SUCH
AS AUTOMATION. ROBOTS
TEMPERATURE MOISTURIZER SENSORS
SALAS SATELLITE IMAGES IMAGING
AND GPS TECHNOLOGY. THESE
SYSTEMS ARE ALSO ALLOWING
BUSINESSES TO BE MORE PROFITABLE
EFFICIENT SAFER FOR WORKERS AND
MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
AG FOOD TECH AG FOOD TECH START
UPS IN CALIFORNIA SAW OVER FOUR
POINT NINE BILLION IN VENTURE
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BY FAR THE
MOST OF ANY STATE. TWICE AS MUCH
AS THE REMAINING TOP TOP FIVE
STATES COMBINED AND A QUARTER OF
THE WORLDWIDE TOTAL. IN ORDER
FOR CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO BE
THE FIRST TO BE THE FOREFRONT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION IN
AGRICULTURAL IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AGRICULTURAL
INNOVATIONS THAT PREPARE THE
WORKFORCE NEEDED TO SUPPORT THEM
. TECHNOLOGY AND AGRICULTURE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL WORKFORCE. WILL
ALLOW MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THE PUBLIC TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS NEW INNOVATING SECTOR
AND IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE UPON IT
. THE OVER REACHING GOALS OF
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE ARE TO
UNDERSTAND. URGING ACT TECH
INDUSTRY AND DISCUSS. AND
DISCUSS WHAT WE AS LEGISLATORS
MAY NEED TO DO TO PREPARE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF ACT TECH
WORKERS. IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE'RE GOING WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING. THIS HEARING IS
ONLY ONE OF THE SERIES HEARINGS
THROUGH THE THROUGH THESE
UPCOMING MONTHS DESIGNED TO FOR
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE PUBLIC ON TOPICS THAT
INTEREST AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER AGRICULTURE RELATED
WORKFORCE. DURING TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BEGIN OUR JOURNEY
WITH A BROADER VIEW ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF AGRICULTURE
TECHNOLOGY WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA I WILL BE HEARING
FROM. CURRENT PRACTITIONERS WHO
ARE DEVELOPING AND USING ACT
TECHNOLOGY IN THE FIELD. WE ALSO
LEARNED ABOUT AG TECHNOLOGY
CHALLENGES BARRIERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND HOW IT IS
LIKELY TO SHAPE OUR FUTURE OF
AGRICULTURE WORKFORCE. WITH THIS
IN MIND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
MEMBERS TODAY IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE ANY OPEN REMARKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR OF
ONE TO. COMMENDED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF FOR HOSTING THIS HEARING
WHEN YOU'VE OF UNIFIRST SPOKE
WHEN YOU FIRST GOT ELECTED I
TALKED ABOUT. THE IMPORTANCE OF
TECH THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU SHARED
ALSO YOUR PASSION FOR MAKING
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA WORKS FOR
EVERYONE INCLUDING AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL- AND AS- THE
WORD APPLE TO ME MEANS SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TO OTHER
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS- WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
THRIVING ECONOMY FOR EVERYONE.
AND I WAS EXCITED TO BE INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
TODAY IN A SPECIAL HEARING FROM
A NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS
REPRESENTING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT IMPORTANT- MOVERS AND
SHAKERS IN THIS SECTOR BUT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO. FOR US TO ALSO
HEAR FROM EXPERTS IS WHAT SHOULD
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BE DOING
OF COURSE WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE ROLE ON BILLS
SPECIFICALLY BUT IN TERMS OF
OVERSIGHT- THAT'S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT AS WELL SO I LOOK FOR
TO THIS CONVERSATION AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT AND
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF US
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED.
TO ENSURING THAT AG TECH IS
WORKING FOR EVERYONE IN AND ALSO
HELPING TO ELEVATE AS MANY OF
THE JOBS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AS WELL TOO THANK YOU.
PICTURE ANYWHERE ELSE. THANK YOU
AYE ALL I WANTED TO THANK GOD
THE CHAIRMAN FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE ACTUALLY AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN INVOLVED IN
AGRICULTURE DON'T REALIZE HOW
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED THE
INDUSTRY ACTUALLY IS AND YOU
KNOW IT REALLY NEEDS TO HAVE
THOSE EFFICIENCIES AND HAVE LESS
WASTE WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE PRODUCT WITH A SHELF LIFE.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE TO BE VERY
EFFICIENT TO ENSURE THE GETTING
IT TO MARKET GETTING IT. SAFELY
TRANSPORTED AND STREAMLINE- YOU
KNOW AG IS BUSY USING TECHNOLOGY
FOR DECADES IN FACT- YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY WITH IRRIGATION THE
PRECISE AMOUNT OF WATER FLOW
RATE TO A GIVEN PLANT SAVES
MONEY IS MORE EFFICIENT IT'S
MORE PRODUCT YIELD AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REPRESENTING ONE OF THE NATION'S
LEADING AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES
BELIEVE IT OR NOT SOUTH OF THE
GRAPEVINE THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WHICH- IS. LEADS THE NATION IN
NURSERY CROPS AND AVOCADOS. IF
THE LAW NINETEEN STARBIRD AND
TENTH AND EGG LAYING HENS. SAN
DIEGO IS NUMBER ONE. IN THE
NATION AND PART TIME FARMERS AND
SMALL FAMILY FARMS. AND NUMBER
TWO IN FARMS OPERATED BY WOMEN.
WITH THE WITH THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE AS FAR AS NINETEENTH
ON THE LIST FARM COUNTY IN THE
NATION. BUT MY BIGGEST ISSUE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT TO THIS HEARING
IS. HOW CAN WE HELP THE SMALL
FAMILY FARMS THOSE ONES THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S THERE'S BARRIERS TO
TECHNOLOGY THE COST OF
TECHNOLOGY IMPLEMENTING IT- WE
FACE MONUMENTAL ISSUES THE LABOR
SHORTAGE DROUGHT WILDFIRES ALL
OF THESE THINGS THAT WE CAN BE
USING TECHNOLOGY. TO HELP. AND
YOU KNOW A LOT OF TIMES SMALL
FAMILY FARMS THEY HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER FOR A CONDOM USE A
SCALE SHARING EQUIPMENT POSSIBLY
IN THE PURCHASING OF IT OR- HOW
THEY USE THAT. WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS TO TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO
WHAT WE CAN LEGISLATIVELY DUE TO
HELP. THANK YOU THANK YOU. IT'S
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
WANNA THINK THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS HEARING TOGETHER- I
JOKE AND I VISITED- MANY MANY
FORMS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
THANK YOU FOR KIND OF OUTLINING
WHAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DOES BY
I EVERY TIME I AM I HAVE TOWARD
SOME FARMS- PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK ME
YOU'RE FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WOULD YOU KNOW D. AND MAINLY
LIKE WHAT DO YOU HAVE AN AG IN
YOUR DISTRICT IS THE NUMBER ONE
QUESTION AND I ALWAYS RESPOND
ABSOLUTELY I EAT. AND SO ALL OF
US THROUGH UP AND DOWN THE STATE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE AG AG INDUSTRY
BECAUSE WE MAY NOT HAVE A FARMS
IN OURDISTRICT BUT OUR
COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON THOSE
FARMS TO BE FED AND- I KNOW
THAT- DOES THAT CENTRAL VALLEY
ARE CALIFORNIA IT SUPPLIES 60%
OF THE PRODUCE FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY SO NOT ONLY IS THAT
A CALIFORNIA ISSUE BUT IT REALLY
IS A NATIONAL ISSUE OF IF OUR
FARMS ARE NOT OF. YOU KNOW
TAKING CARE OF IN OUR FARMERS
ARE NOT TAKING CALVE AND THE
WORKERS AS WELL THEN THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY WILL SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES AS WELL SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE ARE YOU PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
YOU KNOW COME UP WITH SOME
SOLUTIONS ARE SOME IDEAS ON HOW
WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO FIND YOU KNOW A
100% AGREEMENT ONANYTHING BUT
IF WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN DO FOR-
THE FARMS IN THE STATE IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK WE WILL ALL.
BENEFIT BENEFIT FROM IT SO THANK
YOU AGAIN AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING THE PANELISTS TODAY
THANK WILL SAID MR COOPER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE
YOU PUTTING. THIS PANEL
TOGETHER- THINK ABOUT AG THERE
SO MUCH AGNES. SAID CAL.
CALIFORNIA FOR NATION. THE
BIGGEST INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA'S
NOT TECHNOLOGIES AGRICULTURE.
IT'S UPWARDS OF FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND PROBABLY A TO
ME IT'S A LOT HIGHER THAN FIFTY
BILLION- THAT WE FEED IT THAT'S-
CALPERS BIGGEST ECONOMY AND YET
WE MAKE IT SO. TOUGH ON AG AND
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES. I'VE GOT A LOT OF
COMMODITIES IN MY DISTRICT- AS
FAR AS GRAPES GO. 20% GRAPES
GROWN IN CALIFORNIA GOING TO MY
DISTRICT. AND IT'S HAVING BEEN
HERE SEVEN YEARS AND BUILT OVER
SIXTY TOWARDS LONG TOURS WITH
MISS RUBIO. YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN
A LOT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HOW
TOUGH IT IS. TO DO THE JOB IN
THIS TECHNOLOGY COMING IN MORE
MORE. WITH A WORKER. SHORTAGE IS
EXACERBATED. WHAT FRUSTRATES ME
FOR MY COLLEAGUES NOT FROM THE-
AG REGIONS IS THIS IS THE RULES
WE DO. AND THE LAWS WE IMPOSE
MAKE IT SO TOUGH ON AG WE'RE
DRIVES UP COSTS FOR THE
CONSUMER. IT MAKES IT SO MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE I MEAN FOR
INSTANCE. WHEN KERR SAYS YOU
CAN'T USE THIS TRACTOR IN
CALIFORNIA BUT YET. USE THAT
SAME TRACTOR THE RULES IN THE
STATES THE U. S. OF THE WORLD-
THAT'S DIFFICULT FOR SOMEONE AG
INDUSTRY TO DO THAT. SO THEY
FACE A LOT OF REGULATIONS AND
NOT JUST THE TECHNOLOGY BUT JUST
INDUSTRIAL ON ON THE FIELD.
TESTIFIED FOR A NUMBER OF USES.
WORDS CALIFORNIA SPENDS TO LIVE
ALREADY. THEY HAVE TO HAVE FOOD
TO LIVE. THAT'S WITH THE BIGGEST
COST THINK ABOUT IT IS HOUSING
FOOD. THEN BAGASSE IS CRAZY
RIGHT NOW TOO SO IT'S JUST IT'S
SO TOUGH SO. YOU KNOW WE'RE
HEADED THERE AND YOU KNOW WITH
SOME OF THE FOLKS- DON'T SEE AND
DON'T WANT TECHNOLOGY WILL TEAR.
IN IT AND IT'S CHANGING. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HELP AG. I SAID
IT'S OUR- IN THIS CAL. BUT
THEY'RE TREATED THE SAME CLASS
CITIZENS ON A LOT O ISSUES YOUR
BILL TOWARDS AND SEEING THAT'S
THAT'S- THAT'S MY THING MY
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE HERE. IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU HERE IN HERE
THIS AND- IT WILL BE MORE GONNA
CHANGE IN PEOPLE WANT. GOOD
HEALTHY CLEAN FOOD WE WANT WHAT
WE DON'T WANT TO BOB FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. ANOTHER STATE IN
YOU THINK ABOUT RULES AND
REGULATIONS IN THE WE HAVE SAFE
FOOD HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
SOMETIMES WE WERE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE FARMERS AND RANCHERS ARE
TRYING TO THE CELL. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL AND-
GETTING EDUCATED THANK YOU. I DO
PRE. THE COMMENTS ALTERNATE
FUMER. BUT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT A LOT
OF YOU DO PUT ON THESE TOURS. AS
IN MY DISTRICT. WHICH IS I'M
RIGHT NEXT TO COOPER I DO HAVE-
A HUMONGOUS PART OF AG YOU KNOW
FROM CHERRIES TO. TO ALMONDS TO
- WE ONCE HAD A SPARE IS THAT'S
ALL GONE NOW YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TOMATOES WE HAVE GRAPES- BUT
WHAT I WHAT I ENJOY ABOUT THE
TOURS IS THIS. AS MUCH AS I
THINK I KNOW. I DON'T KNOW RIGHT
I LEARNED SOMETHING ON ALL THESE
TOURISTS MORE THAN EVER. I
LEARNED MORE THAT THE INVESTMENT
THAT THAT FARMERS PUT IN- I ALSO
LEARNED THAT. YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
PEOPLE THINK IT'S GENERATIONAL
RIGHT THAT IT GOES ON TO THE
NEXT GENERATION OF EITHER FAMILY
OR KIDS. BUT EVEN THEIR KIDS ARE
FEARING THAT RIGHT I MEAN I'VE
TALKED A LOT OF THIS. THE NEXT
GENERATION THAT THE FEAR THAT
SOMEWHERE I MEAN HEARING THAT
YOU KNOW THEY MAY NOT TURN TO
THIS. BECAUSE THEY SEE HOW HARD.
THEY OR THEIR FAMILY HOW HARD TO
WORKERS HOW HARD IS EVEN THE JOB
SHORTAGE- SO IT'S DIFFICULT SO
I'M I'M JUST VERY THANKFUL AT
SWANSEA THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS
THAT DO PUT ON THE STORES. ALL
TURN TO MEMBER- AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- HIS THIS IRONIC
YES I WENT TO- WAS IN MY
DISTRICT AND THEN- BRAND NEW
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR- BIOMASS
PLANT IS OUT THE RICE HOLDING
COMPANY IN WILLIAMS. AND THEY
INVESTED THIS THEY LEVERAGE
FUNDING TO DO THAT- IN THE
QUESTION ONE OF THE MANY
QUESTIONS I ASKED HIMBECAUSE
IT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS THAT. WHAT DO
YOU DO ABOUT YOUR WORKFORCE
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE PEOPLE TO
RUN THIS NEW PLANT. AND HE WAS
QUITE FRANK WITH ME THIS IS
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. IS TRYING TO
FIND THE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
BECAUSE THESE ARE BIG COMPUTERS
AND TECHNOLOGY. TO RUN THE
PLANT. AND HE OBVIOUSLY
SUGGESTED. LOG COMMITTEE
COLLEGES NEED TO FUNNEL MORE
PEOPLE IN OUR CITY AND FROM THE
HIGH SCHOOLS NEED TO FUNNEL MORE
KIDS IN BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE'RE USING OUR CULTURE IS
REALLY CHANGING ON HOW WE DO
BUSINESS- AND THE OTHER ONE IS
WE TALKED ABOUT- THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. AND THE ISSUE THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE PORTS AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO GET OUR EXPORTS
OUT. AND IF HE SAID IF THERE WAS
DATA COLLECTION AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
YOUR PRODUCT FROM THE MINUTE IT
LEAVES OUR WAREHOUSE TO THE
MINUTE IT ARRIVES. AT ITS
DESTINATION IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE A
CALIFORNIA QUALITY FOR
CALIFORNIA BRAND OF PRODUCTS GOT
TO WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GO
SO ITHINK THERE'S SO MUCH-
OPPORTUNITY HERE THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT. YOU KNOW FARMERS ARE
SMART A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THAT
THEY DON'T REALLY ADHERE TO THIS
BUT THEY WATCH THEIR WATER THEIR
TYPE ONE LET'S JUST FACE HIGH
QUALITY. AND WE DO NOT WANT TO
SPEND AN EXTRA PENNY BUT WE WANT
TO DO IT RIGHT SO I THINK THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE A GOOD
CONVERSATION THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THE OTHERS WILL
SEE NINE- WILL WE WERE BEGIN
WITH OUR- FIRST PANEL.
REGRETTABLY A SECOND FOR A CARE
ROSS WILL NOT ABLE TO JOIN US
TO. IN PERSON DUE TO MANY
OVERLAPPING- COMMITMENTS TODAY
HOWEVER SHE SHE WILL SHARE A
LETTER WITH THIS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SENDS HER REGARDS
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL
AND INTRODUCE GABBRO YOU'D SEE.
CHIEF INNOVATION OFFICER AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
MORNING BUT MY POINT IS RIGHT
THE CLOSEST MICROPHONE HERE ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN-
VIA FULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING TO BEGIN THE DIALOGUE
WITH YOU. MY NAME IS GABE JASSI
CHIEF INNOVATION OFFICER FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES RIGHT LEAD THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF NOVEL-
AGRICULTURE TECHNOLOGIES AND
SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF INNOVATION
AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP- FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD NAG INDUSTRIES
. WHAT YOU SEE IN OUR HAS BEEN
AT THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND THE
VISION OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS- WHOSE WORK IS TO ADVANCE
THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY. AND
STEWART ARE WORKING LANDS UP
THROUGH A NETWORK OF CAMPUS AND
FIELD BASED- SCIENTISTS-
ENGINEERS ON NEARLY EVERY UC
CAMPUS AND EVERY COUNTING
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF YOU SEE AN ARTS
WORK IN THE RESTORATION OF
FUNDING- THAT WILL PUT MUCH
NEEDED PRACTICAL SCIENCE AND
EXPERTISE- AB THE TECHNOLOGY OF
PARTIES BACK IN THE FIELD TO
SUPPORT THE CHALLENGING. TIMES
AHEAD BUT THE OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL FOR CALIFORNIA'S AG
INDUSTRY. CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
AS IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED HAS
LONG BEEN THE BACKBONE OF
AMERICA'S FRESH FOOD SUPPLY.
PRODUCING A THIRD OF THE
NATION'S- VEGETABLES AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE FRUITS AND NUTS.
THAT TRANSLATES INTO FIFTY
BILLION IN PHARMACY TO NEARLY
FIFTY BILLION BAHT- TO YOUR
POINT TO WELL OVER THREE HUNDRED
BILLION AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION JOBS. ACROSS THE STATES
WORKING LANDSCAPES AS WE FOUND
YOU SEEN OUR FOUND IN A TWENTY
NINETEEN STUDY. THESE JOBS ARE
OFTEN LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA'S
RURAL COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
CENTRAL SALINAS IMPROVE ALEX.
HOWEVER STATE'S AGRICULTURAL
LEADERSHIP AND EVEN THE ABILITY
TO FEED OUR POPULATION IS UNDER
THREAT DUE TO THE ONE TWO PUNCH
IS A CLIMATE CHANGE A SHRINKING
WORKFORCE. AND COMPETITION FROM
MEXICO AND ELSEWHERE WHICH IS
LARGELY IS DRIVEN BY REGULATIONS
AND OTHER CHALLENGES. CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL LEADERSHIP IS A
HERITAGE WORTH FIGHTING FOR.
PART OF THE ANSWER LIES IN ONE
EMBRACING NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WILL MAKE THE INDUSTRY MORE
RESILIENT SUSTAINABLE PROFITABLE
AND EQUITABLE INTO INVESTING IN
OUR WORKFORCE THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL INVENT OPERATE IN SEWER
INDUSTRY IN A BETTER FUTURE. THE
EMERGING AD TECH INDUSTRY HAS
EXPERIENCED EXPLOSIVE GROWTH IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS AS WAS
MENTIONED IN THE INVESTMENT IS
INCREASING FOR SOLUTIONS FOR
SUSTAINABLE FARMING HEALTHY FOOD
AND SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE
AMONG OTHER THINGS. THIS HAS
BEEN DRIVEN BY BOTH BY LARGER
FARMING FOOD INCUMBENTS BUT ALSO
BY SILICON VALLEY INVESTORS AND
TECHNOLOGISTS. AND MUCH OF MY
AND OTHERS IN THIS ROOM TO WORK
IS TO BRIDGE THE VERY LARGE
BUSINESS AND CULTURAL GAPS.
BETWEEN AGRICULTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY. BUT THE WRITINGS ON
THE WALL. INNOVATIONS SUCH AS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
BIOLOGICAL ADVANCES OF SUCH AS
CRISPR. IN CLOUD COMPUTING ARE
DEMONSTRATING THAT AGTECH IS
HERE TO STAY. AND WILL CONTINUE
TO TRANSFORM THE WAY WE GROW UP
AND AS WELL AS CONSUME FOOD.
THAT MEANS CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL WORKFORCE MUSH MUST
LOOK MUCH DIFFERENT IN THE
COMING YEARS AND WE MUST PREPARE
FOR THAT STARTING WITH TODAY'S
PROFESSIONALS. AS WELL AS OUR
COLLEGE LEVEL INVENTORS AND
OPERATORS AND OUR YOUNG SCHOOL
CHILDREN. IT'S A CHALLENGE TO
ATTRACT YOUNG PEOPLE INTO THE AG
INDUSTRY AS THEY IMAGINE OR HEAR
STORIES FROM PARENTS ABOUT
BACKBREAKING WORK AND LOW PAY.
THE REALITY IS THERE ARE MANY
HIGH PAYING REWARDING CAREERS IN
AG INDUSTRY. AND AS THE FOOD AN
ACTIVE SECTORS- BECOME MORE
DIGITISED THERE WILL BE MANY
MORE. THE NEED WE SEE IS THAT
THAT WORKERS AT ALL LEVELS FROM
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS TO
GREENHOUSE TECHNICIANS TO
IRRIGATION PEST MANAGEMENT
SPECIALIST ALL NEED MORE CROSS
DISCIPLINARY KNOWLEDGE. THEY
NEED TO HAVE SKILLS THAT SPAN
AGRICULTURE BIOLOGY COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING. WE NEED
TO HAVE FARM EXPERTISE AND KNOW
HOW TO USE ABSENT MACHINES AND
EVENTUALLY ROBOTS. THESE
DISCIPLINES ARE TRADITIONALLY
ODD BEDFELLOWS AND I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND STRUGGLE IN ALIGNING
THE WORLD'S OF AGON TACK TO
CREATE NOVEL NEW CURRICULUM TO
TRAIN AND PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
THE FUTURE. LET ME GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF APPROACHES WERE
TAKEN RIGHT NOW- UC DAVIS UC
AGONISTS RESOURCES UC BERKELEY
AND OTHERS HAVE CREATED A NEW
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE FOR THE
FOOD SYSTEM INSTITUTE. WHERE
WE'RE DEVELOPING A LOT OF THESE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE PLACING UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CSU AND UC LEVELS. IN
THE COMPANIES TO LEARN THIS TACK
AND DO ALONGSIDE THEIR STUDIES
WITH PAID OPPORTUNITIES NOT FREE
- YOU SEE IN OUR IS PARTING WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- LET HER KNOW
WHO HER FROM IN A MINUTE. AND
HIGH SCHOOLS TO HELP UPSKILL
THEIR INSTRUCTORS IN A TRAIN THE
TRAINER MODEL- TO LEARN THESE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND BRING THEM
BACK INTO THEIR CLASSROOMS. OUR
NEXT GENERATION OF UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
PROFESSIONALS ARE CONDUCTING-
AND HAVE FOR MANY YEARS FEEL
DAYS FOR FARMERS AND AG WORKERS
IN ENGLISH AND SPANISH. BUT ARE
ALSO INCORPORATING NEW TECH
READY OF NEW TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS
THE LATEST SPRAY TECHNOLOGY OR
MECHANICAL HARVESTING. SOMEONE
MENTIONED I CREATED A NEW
EXAMPLE AFTER THE MENTION ABOUT
SMALL FARMS- AND A SMALL FARMS
IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY. IMPORTANT
COMPONENT IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO
THERE'S A VARIETY OF NEW
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
LIKE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW
FOOD HUB- IN- IN YOLO COUNTY AND
FOOD HUBS ARE ARE POPPING UP
AROUND THE STATE AS WELL. AS
WELL AS A SMALL- FARM TECHNOLOGY
LENDING LIBRARY IN THE FRESNO
REGION- LET OUT OF OUR CURRENT
FACILITY- NEAR PARLAY- IT'S
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT THAT WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP US SMALL
FARMERS THERE'S A WILL THERE'S-
A VARIETY OF OTHER EXAMPLES I
COULD GIVE. THESE ARE IMPORTANT
BUT ONLY A DROP IN THE BUCKET OF
WHAT'S NEEDED TO TRANSFORM OUR
FOOD NICK WORKFORCE.
OPPORTUNITIES THERE NOT ONLY TO
MAKE- TODAY'S AGRICULTURE
ECONOMY MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
PROFITABLE. BUT I BELIEVE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF AGTECH CAN
CAN COMPLETELY TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S RURAL ECONOMIES
BIOBASED PRODUCTS AND MATERIALS
THAT USED- WASTE AS INGREDIENTS
. NEW CROPS AND FARMING METHODS
LIKE STRAWBERRIES GROWN VERTICAL
FARMS NEW FOODS LIKE ALTERNATIVE
PROTEINS ARE ALL YOU KNOW
DEMONSTRATIONS OF THE OF A BIG
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE ECONOMIES IN
PARTICULAR IF WE CAN TAKE
LEADERSHIP OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND INVEST IN THE WORKFORCE.
I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH COUPLE
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT STILL NEEDED
FOR CONSIDERATION THIS
COMMITTEE'S WORK- TO HELP US GET
READY TO GO. ONE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN EDUCATION
ALL LEVELS GRADE SCHOOL THROUGH
UNIVERSITY BY SUPPORTING THOSE
PROGRAMS. THAT ARE WORKING AND
ARE BRINGING NEW YOUNG PEOPLE TO
THE MANY PATHWAYS INTO THE FOOD
BANK SECTOR- MANY PROGRAMS TO
GET STARTED TO GRANT FUNDING
WOULD HAVE A HARD TIME
SUSTAINING AND SCALING. BUT
SECOND TRAIN NEXT GENERATION OF
YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS AND FUSING
THEM WITH THE SKILL SETS TO
SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST
CLIMATE AND FOOD SYSTEM.
RESILIENCE TO CHALLENGE IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT. I NEED TO FOCUS
ON A RURAL COMMUNITIES SO THESE
YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS CAN BUILD
THESE GLOBALLY LEADING COMPANIES
OF THE FUTURE THE GOOGLE FOR AG
I'M FROM THE RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND REVITALIZE OF THE COLONIES.
LAST CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS
WORTH FIGHTING FOR AND THE
FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE AMONG
THE BEST IN THE WORLD. OUR
ABILITY TO FEED OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION. NATIONAL SECURITY
THROUGH FOOD SECURITY IS A
WORTHY AND IMPORTANT GOAL. IN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCES THE FOOD
THAT WE SHOULD BE EATING MORE
FRUITS VEGETABLES AND NUTS. WE
NEED TO WORK FORCE TODAY. A
WORKFORCE THAT DRIVE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF FARMING FOOD
PRODUCTION AND THE FUTURE
BIOECONOMY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION. AND
HOSTING A FARM TOURS IN ANY OF
YOUR DISTRICTS THANKS. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. I'M JUST
A QUICK QUESTION COULD YOU
ELABORATE MORE ON THE SMALL FARM
LENDING HOW THAT'S HOW THEY YEAH
SO THAT PROBLEM IS- IS NOT
GOTTEN OFF THE GROUND JUST YET
WE'VE GOT WE HAVE A UC SMALL
FARMS NETWORK WHICH HAS- SMALL
FARMS ADVISORS THAT ARE LOCATED
ACROSS THE STATE ONE IN
PARTICULAR IN FRESNO COUNTY-
RUTH DAHLQUIST WILLARD WHO WORKS
WITH- SMALL FARMERS PARTICULARLY
FARMERS OF COLOR- IN CREATING
NEW PRODUCTS- SHE HAS REALLY
SEEN THE NEED- FOR TRAINING
SMALL FARMS ON THE USE OF WHAT
YOU WOULD CALL APPROPRIATE
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY COULD
SCALE DOWN AND COST EFFECTIVE
ENOUGH FOR SMALL FARMS TO USE.
BUT THEY'RE STILL A BARRIER IN
KNOWING WAT'S AVAILABLE HOW TO
USE IT AND THEN ACQUIRING IT AND
SO THE IDEA IS THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON NOW THAT WE'RE GOING
TO LIKELY FUNDS FOR SOME GRANT
ENTERPRISE IS TO GET A
COLLECTION OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY THEN WENT
OUT TO FARMERS IN THE REGION- WE
CAN TRAIN ON HOW TO USE IT.
DON'T HAVE TODAY. THAT SOUNDS
REALLY GREAT THANK YOU. THE
OTHERS ON SCENE AND- I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU MISTER C. LIKE
HOW EARLY SHOULD WE BEGIN
TEACHING I MEAN I KNOW I'M SURE
UNIVERSITIES ARE WORKING ON THIS
BUT I'M TALKING AND IN THE- HOT
WHAT'S THAT WOULD WELL EARLY AGE
YOU KNOW- OUR BUYER DIVISION
RUNS THE- ONES. H. FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I THINK WE
BELIEVE THAT SHOULD BEGIN VERY
EARLY IN GRADE SCHOOL. AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR THINK
SOME GREAT EXAMPLES OF
NONTRADITIONAL EDUCATION THAT
GETS KIDS INTO GET DICK
LEARNING- SPACES- REALLY AT THE
GRADE SCHOOL LEVEL I DON'T I
THINK IT'S NOT EVER TOO EARLY TO
START AND I THINK IF WE REALLY
WANT TO GET KIDS INTERESTED IN
TRAJECTORY TRULY IN. CAREERS OF
THE FUTURE HE REALLY TO CAPTURE
THEIR IMAGINATION AND GRADE
SCHOOL SO I THINK TO ME GRADE
SCHOOL IS THE PLACE TO BEGIN.
AND THEN YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY WORK-
THROUGH THROUGH- UNDERGRADUATE
GRADUATE EDUCATION I UNDER
PERCENT AGREE WITH YOU I MEAN WE
- IN OUR- WE- OUR FARM BUREAU.
DOES ORGANIZE- EVENTS WITH
SCHOOLS THAT EARLY AGE IN THE-
IT'S FUN TO WATCH THE KIDS
REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
THEY'RE TOUCHING EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'RE EATING IS LITERALLY. YOU
KNOW COMING FROM A FARM AND
THEY'VE THEY'RE FASCINATED RIGHT
BUT THE FAST THE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HERE IN SCHOOLS RIGHT AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE OF. IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE PARTICULAR HIGH TECH
EITHER IT REALLY JUST BE EX YOU
KNOW THEM EXPERIENCING- FARM AND
WHERE THEIR FOOD COMES FROM IN A
VERY VERY SIMPLE WAY TO CAPTURE
THAT IMAGE AND IMAGINATION FROM
EARLY AGE WE DO THAT A NUMBER OF
ARE YOU SEE LOCATIONS BOTH ON
CAMPUS. AND AROUND THE STATE
CALIFORNIA AND WE PUT IT OUT WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND SCALE THAT UP BECAUSE.
THAT EARLY LEARNING IS JUST SO
IMPORTANT. WHILE WORKING. TO
MANY MORE MORE DISCUSSION WITH
YOU ON THE RIGHT THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT WE HAVE
DENNIS DONOHUE DIRECTOR AT THE
CENTRAL THE CENTER OF INNOVATION
AND TECHNOLOGY AT WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR THE INVITATION TO-
VISIT WITH YOU THIS MORNING THAT
IT'S- HARD NOT TO THINK ABOUT
THE REMARKS I HAD IN MIND AND
THEN TRY AND THINK ON YOUR FEET
TO A RESPOND TO SOME OF THINGS
IS THAT SO WELL. YEAH YEAH. WELL
ALL OF I'LL TRY TO DO IT THEN
THE- AND THEN BEEN UP BY DAVE
HAD A TO SOME- FRIEDMAN IN SALT
I'M GONNA I'M GONNA IMPROVISE A
LITTLE BIT BUT THE FIRST THING I
WANTED TO BESIDES THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO BE HERE- IS
ALSO THANK SECRETARY ROSS WHO
IS- MY PARTNER IN CRIME SO TO
SPEAK FOR A YEAR AND I WANT AND
I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT THAT
PROGRAM BUT I BUT I WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO- THE SECOND PAGE
OF. FOR OUR LETTER TO YOU AND
SHE TALKS VERY MUCH ABOUT.
TECHNOLOGY BEING. THE BRIDGE. TO
THE FUTURE M. AND WE CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THAT AND WE AND WE
APPRECIATE- FOR CALLING
ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AS A- AS WELL
AS WESTERN GROWERS I DO RUN
WESTERN GROWERS CENTER FOR
INNOVATION AND- AND TECHNOLOGY.
I'M THE PROVERBIAL SALES BEEN
MARRIED TO A FARMER'S DAUGHTER
SO I WAS IN THE DEAL AS WE LIKE
TO SAY IN SALINAS FOR THIRTY
YEARS- AND I BELONG TO ALL OF
THE GROUPS WHETHER IT'S PMA
UNITED OR WESTERN GROWERS. AND
WESTERN GROWERS IT'S SOMETHING I
THINK PARTICULARLY IN THE
COMPLEX REPORT ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
YEARS AGO. WHERE WHERE THEY
SAID. THEY SAID WE NEED TO JUMP
INTO THE INNOVATION. AND
TECHNOLOGY AND BE PROACTIVE IN
RATHER THAN. REACTIVE TO THE
FUTURE. AND WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT AG TECH AND THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S REALLY ABOUT THAT
PHRASE- YEAH CAN BE RENEWABLES%
THAT CAN BE ROBOTICS THAT COULD
BE SOFTWARE SERVICE. SO IT'S
REAL IT'S REALLY KIND OF A KIND
OF A CATCH ALL- AND WE- I MAKE
NO DOUBT- EVEN THOUGH YOU VISIT
ALL THOSE FORMS WE DO COMPETE A
LITTLE BIT AMONGST OURSELVES BUT
WE DO COOPERATE PRETTY WELL ON.
TECHNICAL ISSUES REGULATORY
ISSUES AND FOOD SAFETY ISSUES
AMONG WE RECOGNIZE. WHEN IT CAME
TO TECHNOLOGY- AND THEN. THAT
THAT'S- COOPERATE. WERE ALSO
BORN GOING TO MATTER. AND I
APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND IT MAY BE A
LITTLE COUNTER INTUITIVE BUT YOU
KNOW WESTERN GROWERS- OUR
MEMBERSHIP REPRESENTS YOU KNOW
THE FIGURES YOU LAID OUT. ON
AVERAGE TO DEPEND UPON THE CROP
SOME 5260% OF NORTH AMERICA'S
FRESH FRUIT AND VEGETABLE AND
THAT PRODUCTION AND- NEARLY HALF
OF THE ORGANIC PRODUCTION OF
THOSE CATEGORIES. AS WELL. AND
WE'RE OPERATING IN SOME THIRTY
TWO STATES IN THIRTY COUNTRIES
TO GET THAT DONE BECAUSE THE
MARKET PLACE EXPECTS US TO BE IN
ON A- YEAR ROUND BASIS SO WE'RE
THE SPECIALTY CROP CROWD. IT'S A
GLOBAL PLATFORM- IT MAY BE A
LITTLE COUNTER INTUITIVE BUT-
THERE'S- EVERYTHING YOU JUST.
LAID OUT ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S TRUE
THIS IS THE PLACE TO BE- WE HAVE
ENORMOUS ADVANTAGES BUT BECAUSE-
AND I'M SPEAKING AS THE
SPECIALTY CROP CROWD. A LOT OF
THE THINGS WE NEED TO GET DONE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY CROPS.
AND SO MUCH DIVERSITY WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE SCALE WE
NEED TO GET CERTAIN THINGS DONE
UNLESS WE WORK TOGETHER. SO I
MAY BE A LITTLE COUNTER
INTUITIVE BUT ONE OF THE WAYS TO
HELP THE SMALLER FARMERS PROTECT
WE WANT TO COME TO THE
TECHNOLOGY. IS THAT THAT THE
LARGER PLAYERS. ARE GOOD AT GOOD
PLACE OF AGGREGATION TO GET SOME
TECHNOLOGY DON AND CREATE SCALE
AND BATTLE WITH. THAT- THAT
WORKS ON BEHALF OF EVERYBODY SO
FOR INSTANCE- I DON'T AT. CAN
MENTIONED OUR GLOBAL HARVEST
AUTOMATION. INITIATIVE ONE OF
THE THINGS WE FOUND OUT AS WE
LOOKED AT. THE LABOR ISSUE. AT
AS IT IS THAT. WE WERE DOING
PRETTY IN CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES
SUCH AS SPENDING ON WHEAT IN THE
MARKET PLACE WAS WORKING AS I
LIKE TO TELL PEOPLE. THANK R.
TWO D. TWO. REPETITIVE MOVIE
MOVING UP AND DOWN FIELDS. BUT
WHEN YOU START THINKING ABOUT
HARVEST CP THREE OUT I TALKING
ABOUT REPLICATED EGGMAN BIT.
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION MUCH
HIGHER LEVEL OF COMPLEXITY. AND
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
SCALE. CROP BY CROP. FOR A
CUSTOM AUTOMATION. SOLUTION SO
ONE OF THE THINGS WE SAID WAS
WELL LET'S LOOK AT SOME
CALIFORNIA ON AN AGGREGATE BASIS
. AND WE TOOK THE TOP DOZEN OR
SO CROPS THAT WE GROW HERE AND
SAID OKAY. ON AVERAGE WE ON A
GLOBAL. SCALE WE REPRESENT LET'S
SAY 50% OF THE MARKET GIVE OR
TAKE SO THAT MEANS WE REPRESENT
SCALE. SO PROOF OF CONCEPT HAS
TO HAPPEN HERE SO CALIFORNIA HAS
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE
GLOBAL LANDING SPOT. FOR A LOT
OF TECHNOLOGY WE THINK THAT'S A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA.
FOR OUR INDUSTRY FOR RURAL RURAL
ECONOMIES AND SO WE AGGREGATED.
AND WHAT WE BASICALLY DID WAS WE
LOOKED AT- SPECIALLY CRAFTED
SAID THREE THINGS ARE HAPPENING
YOU'RE GETTING THINGS OFF THE
GROUND OUT OF A TREE A CLIP FROM
A BY. NOW HOW DO YOU GET THAT
DONE SO FOR INSTANCE ONE OF OUR-
AND JUST PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S- FOOD FOR
THOUGHT A LITTLE BIT FOR ALL OF
US. ONE OF OUR FAVORITE BRADLEY
GROWER SHIPPERS WE HAD AMAJOR
JAPANESE CORPORATION ROBOTICS
PLAYER IN THE FIELD. THIS
COMPANY REPRESENTED 25% OF THE
U. S. BROCCOLI FLORETS
FOODSERVICE MARKET OPPORTUNITY
AND I LOOK AT THE GIRL AND I
SAID NOW TELL TELL THEM HOW MANY
YOU'RE GOING TO BUY AND I
THOUGHT THE ANSWER WAS GOING TO
BE BIGGER. AND HE SAID TO. FIVE
SO WHAT'S GREAT THE ADDRESSABLE
MARKET IS TEN. TRUST ME WHEN I
TELL YOU. DOWN THERE AND MAKE
INTO. SO NOW BUT- THAT'S ALSO
OUR OPPORTUNITY. BECAUSE WE
BECAUSE TO WILL GET MAY. THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU MARRY.
SMALL NUMBERS WITH SOPHISTICATED
TECHNOLOGY BUT THAT BECOMES OUR
OPPORTUNITY. AND IF AND YOU KNOW
SO WE THANK AND WE APPRECIATE
CAN POINTING THIS UT THAT IF WE
CAN STEP IN AS INDUSTRY. AND
PROVIDE CLEAR DIRECTION OF
HERE'S WHAT WE NEED THAT'S
HELPFUL. AND THAT ACCELERATES
ACCELERATES THE PROCESS SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THE
GLOBAL HARVEST AUTOMATION
INITIATIVE IS TRYING TO DO. I
RUN WESTERN GROWERS INNOVATION
CENTER AND ORIGINALLY STARTED
WITH A PRETTY SIMPLE IDEA LET'S
GET TECHNOLOGY TOGETHER WITH
GROWERS AND- STUFF WILL HAPPEN
REAL FAST RON. MUCH MUCH SLOWER
PROCESS TAKES A LITTLE LONGER.
THAN WE DAHLE PREFERRED SO WE
REALIZED WE NEEDED TO START WORK
MORE STRATEGICALLY. AND
INTENTIONALLY. AND IN THAT
PROCESS IT BECAME VERY VERY
CLEAR. THAT THE FOLKS. TO THE
COMMENTS YOU MADE ABOUT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ONE DAY
JUST TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. NEEDED TO
BE ADDRESSED SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER. AND WE NEEDED TO BE
INTENTIONAL AND WE NEED TO SEE
IF WE COULD ACCELERATE THAT SO
PART OF WHAT WE DO. AT WESTERN
GROWERS AND THROUGH INNOVATION
CENTERS WE DO SOME PROGRAMMING
AND SO- KAREN AND I- WE'RE DOING
AN EVENT TOGETHER APART NOW. AND
I I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S I ALSO ON
THE FORMER MAYOR OF SALINAS
AGTECH WAS MY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU READ THE TWO
STICKS TOGETHER THE SALINAS
FRANCES VALLEY ON THE PLANET THE
INNOVATORS MOST INNOVATIVE VALUE
TO THE PLANET. WHAT A GAP. M. AS
I LEFT OFFICE SINCE CONTINUE TO
MY CAREER. I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH A YOUNG MAN WHO DOES ALL
THE INNOVATION WORK FOR HIS
FAMILY'S COMPANY AND HE SAID I
WAS TELLING MY DAD EVERYONE I
DEAL WITH. IS EITHER AG. FOR
TACK HOW DO WE GET IT. IT'S
ALMOST LIKE WE NEED A NEW KIND
OF WORKER. THAT SHARED THAT WITH
KAREN. AND THAT WITH THEM WHAT
WAS REALLY KIND OF BORN OUT OF
THAT IS. CAN WHY DON'T WE- TAKE
A YEAR FOCUS. AND MOVE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE USING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS THE
PLATFORM AN APP FOR
CONVERSATIONS AND WE CHOSE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR A REASON
BECAUSE WE THINK THEY'RE THE
PERFECT INTERSECTION. FOR ALL
STUDENTS COMING. COMING UP THE
CHAIN THEY'RE ALSO IN THE UP
SKILLING BUSINESS OF PROVIDING
CERTIFICATES THEY'RE A PERFECT
SPOT TO GO DIRECTLY AND ASK IF
YOU WANT FOR ON TWO WAY FOR YOUR
SCHOOL AND THEN AND THEN OF
COURSE THEY HAVE CLEAR LINE OF
SIGHT LIVES GAVE SAID FOUR H.
FFA IS AND THAT SORT OF THING SO
WE THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE. THE
PERFECT. VEHICLE TO DO SO WE
LAUNCHED. AND I PROVIDED THIS
WITH YOU IN A KIND OF A PITCH
SOMETIMES. A PICTURE SAYS THIS
BETTER BETTER THAN I COULD SO
WE- CHOSE FOR SCHOOLS. WE
STARTED. AUGUST TWENTIETH SIX
BEEN REGALLY AT REEDLEY COLLEGE.
WILL BE DOWN IN IMPERIAL VALLEY
COLLEGE AND THE END OF JANUARY
BACK APARTMENT ALL. IN THE
MIDDLE OF APRIL AND THEN WE
CLOSE IN A VERY EXCITED ABOUT
CLOSING HERE PARTICULARLY OF
YOUR ALL'S INTEREST. IN THIS AT
WOODLAND COMMUNITY COLLEGE JUNE
ONE AND TWO. AND THE IDEA IS TO.
MOVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE. HAVE
THIS VERY CONVERSATION. AT IT
AND IF YOU LOOK ON THE BACK PAGE
THE FORMAT IS BASED BASICALLY
THE SAME WE'RE GONNA BRING IN
INDUSTRY. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
SAY. THIS IS WHAT WE NEED LOUDLY
AND CLEARLY. THAT WE'RE GONNA
BRING IN EDUCATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. AND SAY THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING OR INTENDED TO-
AND THE IDEAS YOU KNOW THE
REGIONAL COLLEGE. IS THE HOST
BUT WE HAVE TO WE BRING IN THE
OTHER PLAYERS CELESTIALS WAS
THERE- UC MERCED CAME DOWN THAT
THAT TYPE OF THING- POM
WONDERFUL HAS A CHARTER SCHOOL
SO THE IDEA IS TO REPRESENT. THE
YEAH YOU KNOW THE WHOLE AREA
WHO'S DOING WHAT AND SO WE'LL
MOVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO DO
THAT AND THEN WE HAVE A CEO
PANEL WHICH IS IMPORTANT. TO
SAVE ON BEHALF OF INDUSTRY
LEADERSHIP. AND THE SPEECH NEEDS
TO BE GIVEN TO OURSELVES
SOMETIMES IS INDUSTRY THIS IS
IMPORTANT. THIS NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
AND WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF IT. AND
THEN AND THEN KAREN AND I'VE CAN
FINISH UP WITH A WITH A
CONVERSATION. AND THESE ARE
THESE ARE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CYCLES AND THEN THE NEXT MORNING
WE WILL. SPEND TIME WITH
GENERALLY STUDENTS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO WE WANT YOUNG PEOPLE TO
BE EXCITED ABOUT AG. BUT IT'S A
MUCH DEEPER. THAT THE PROPERTIES
ARE BROADER DEEPER MORE ROBUST
THAN THEY OFTEN OFTEN REALIZE
SO- AND- THE IDEA WILL BE. WHAT
OF WHICH ONE WE GET BACK HERE TO
WOODLAND WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED
AND WHERE THE GAPS WHAT DID WE
LEARN AND READ LIKE SO YOU'VE
ALREADY ASKED THE QUESTION HOW
SOON DO WE START SO ONE OF THE-
SCHOOLS WE HAD UP THERE WAS THE
MCFARLAND DISTRICT AND IF YOU
LIKE- KEVIN COSTNER TRACK. GUESS
WHAT ONE OF HIS LEVY THIS WAS
THEY HAVE A GREAT ROBOTICS
PROGRAM AND SO THE
SUPERINTENDENT TOOK US THROUGH
AND KAREN HAVE THIS FOR THE
GRAMMAR SCHOOL THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
BY HIGH SCHOOL THE GRAMMAR
SCHOOL HAS THREE MAKERSPACES. SO
YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF YOUNG.
CHILDREN WHO WERE EXCITED MAKING
THINGS AND ALREADY GETTING THAT
STEM BASED EDUCATION SO WHAT DID
WE LEARN START AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS WE'RE LEARNING IS THERE'S
GOING TO BE A TEACHER GAP. WHO'S
GONNA TEACH THIS STUFF. BECAUSE
YOU CAN HAVE A LOT OF TERRIFIC.
TEACHERS BUT THEY ARE YOU KNOW
YOU MENTIONED IRRIGATION THEY
MAY HAVE A BACKGROUND IN YOUR
NATION THAT THAT THAT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY GETS READY TO GO TO
TALK TO TALK ABOUT ROBOTICS AND
AI BUT BUT WE ALSO SO RELAY FOR
INSTANCE IS BRINGING IN INDUSTRY
PEOPLE THEY FACILITATE THE
CONVERSATION. TO START THE
PROCESS BUT THIS ISSUE OF
TEACHING. JOB SHADOWING. IT'S
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE SO WHAT WE
TRY TO DO IS FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE ISSUE IS ONE OF THE GAPS
WHAT ARE. WHAT ARE THE WHAT'S
THE ACTUAL BANDWIDTH BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A WORLD. OF
SCALE- AS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
BOB SO. HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WE
GONNA NEED AND HOW WE THINK HOW
DO WE FIGURE THIS OUT SO THOSE
ARE A COUPLE OF. TAKEAWAYS AND
THEN THE OTHER THING I THINK YOU
SHOULD. WILL BE BE. EXCITED
ABOUT IT THEN I GOT A FEW PHONE
CALLS AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE HEY
HOW COME YOU DIDN'T BITE ME AND-
YOU KNOW SO I MEAN I. AM A
FORMER MAYOR I KNOW HOW TO DO IT
A LOT WELL YOU KNOW. THAT YOU
CAN GET THE EVERYONE BUT- WE
HEARD FROM SUCH A SMALL
COMMUNITY. IN SANGER. THAT A
GROUP OF PARENTS. AND THE
SCHOOL. GRAMMAR IN A GRAMMAR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. THEY WANT TO
BUILD A CASE THROUGH AGE.
DEDICATED GRAMMAR SCHOOL THAT IS
SOLELY BASED ON ITS OWN IT'S
ALMOST LIKE A LAND GRANT
UNIVERSITY WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THE EQUIVALENT OF A AG AT.
GRAMMAR SCHOOL METAL BE
FOUNDATIONAL THAT WAS PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE IN PRETTY EXCITING.
YOU KNOW THAT THE PRINCIPLE- YOU
KNOW I COULD PUT HIM ON A SUNDAY
MORNING WITH ANY OF ANALYST
PRETTY GOOD. OFF START THE KIDS
YOUNG SO THOSE WERE THINGS WERE
LEARNING AND FIND IT OUT SO IT'S
VERY EXCITING TO MOVE THROUGH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND- AND
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO REALLY
BRING IT BACK. THAT KIND OF THAT
COMPOSITE. PICTURE TO YOU ALL.
BY THE TIME WE GET TO A- GET GET
THE WOODLAND. SO THAT'S THE
NATURE OF THE PROGRAM. WE ASKED
THAT SAME QUESTION. YOU ASKED
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO AND SAID HOW
DO WE GET THAT KIND OF WORKERS
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO HAVE THAT AND THE OTHER
THING THAT TIPPED ME OFF WAS WE
STARTED TO GET A LOT OF YOUR-
ENTREPRENEURIAL ACTIVITY. AND
THEY SAID WE CAN'T FIND SALES
PEOPLE. OKAY SO I CAN MAKE
STUFF. BUT IF I CAN'T GET IT
SOLD GET IT SERVICE SO SEVENTY
SO WE AND SO IT'S NOT JUST A
QUESTION OF. TECHNOLOGY IN A
VACUUM YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THE
STUFF THAT GOES WITH IT. AND LET
ME JUST CLOSE WITH THAT SINCE I
LISTEN TO SOME OF YOUR COMMENTS
I AM A FORMER MAYOR AND- MY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY.
CONSISTS SALINAS IS A RELATIVELY
AT THE TIME. JUST BECAUSE OUR
STRUCTURAL BORDERS. WAS A
RELATIVELY POOR CITY. IN TERMS
OF- OUR OUR GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
SO MY THOUGHT WAS OK HOW IF I
HANG OUT UP NORTH AND IT WAS A
CITY AVERAGE AGE OF TWENTY SIX.
YEARS OLD HOW DO WE CREATE.
OPPORTUNE THE OPPORTUNE. TO
BRING AG TACK. AND MAINTAIN THE
HEALTH OF THE WORLD ECONOMY IS.
IT IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE. AND WHERE YOU HAVE A
HEALTHY AG COMMUNITY. AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT ALL THE TRANSITIONS
WERE GOING THROUGH WHETHER
EXACT. THERE TENDS TO BE
EDUCATION THERE TENDS TO BE
HEALTHCARE. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT TIME LINE UP WHEN AG
IS HEALTHY. AND I AND I THINK WE
HAVE SOME HUGE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR. CUSTOM MANUFACTURING. AND
THEN I WOULD JUST SHARE AND I
THINK GAVE MADE A TERRIFIC POINT
. THERE IS WAY MORE TALENT THAN
I THINK PEOPLE SOMETIMES EXPECT
TO FIND IN THESE. IN THIS
COMMUNITY IN MONTANA AND- MY
DIRECT EXPERIENCE IS THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHOSE FAMILY HAS FARMED
WORKED IN THE FIELDS. HAVE THAT
HAVE A MARVELOUS INTO IT SOUNDS.
FOR AGRICULTURE. AND THE TRICK
IS GETTING CITED ABOUT A FUTURE
NAG AS OPPOSED TO WHAT I WANT TO
DO WITH MY FOLKS AND- GUESS WHAT
THE FOLKS PROBABLY DON'T WANT
YOU TO DO IT EITHER. YEAH BUT
THEY BUT THAT THE BLACK. THERE
IS. SOMETHING TO BE GOING FROM
THAT EXPERIENCE THAT THEY ALL
HAD. AND IF WE CAN BUILD UPON
THAT COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY I
WAS A STATE. IT'S A HUGE HUGE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAINTAIN A
REVITALIZED STUFF. OUR RURAL
COMMUNITY ITSELF. I WAS. I'LL
JUST. CLOSE WITH A YOU KNOW- YOU
KNOW AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE I
WOULD I WAS A GROWER RIGHT. I'VE
I WAS KIND OF SHARING INSIDE A
LITTLE BIT WHEN I HEARD
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER SPEAKING.
BUT YET I COULDN'T HELP MYSELF
IT WAS. INSIDE A DENTURE OUT
LOUD. YEAH THE YOU YOU WILL HEAR
FOR. OF COURSE WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE TARGETED YOU'LL GET. A LOT OF
GOOD ADVICE BUT IF I WERE TO
GIVE ANY ADVICE. AND I DON'T GET
PAID TO THANK ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN GROWERS I JUST DO
ANIMATION. IT WOULD BE LISTEN TO
THE GROWERS. BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU THE PEOPLE I'VE DEALT WITH
IN TERMS OF THE COMMUNITY AS
FELLOW INDUSTRY FOLKS. THERE I'M
A BIG FAN OF THE SAINT OF GEORGE
WASHINGTON CARVER THE CHALLENGE
IS TO DO THE COMMON THINGS.
UNCOMMONLY WELL NOW YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM DON CAMERON LATER
TRUST ME WHEN I TELL YOU HE DOES
THE COMMON THING. UNCOMMONLY
WELL WHEN IT COMES TO MAKE
THINGS BUT ALSO THESE ARE
TERRIFIC BUSINESSPEOPLE AND IT
IS IN THEIR DNA. TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. AND IF YOU LISTEN TO
THEM AND MAKE THEM PART OF THE
PROCESS AND NOT NECESSARILY GET
AHEAD OF OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND
YOU'D BE I THINK YOU'D BE
AMAZED- AND I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO YOUR
COMMENTS IF WE WORK TOGETHER.
YOU'D BE YOU'D BE AMAZED WHAT
COULD HAPPEN BUT YEAH IT WOULD
BE A SHAME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
GIVE AWAY ITS PLACE ON THE
PLAYING FIELD- FOR REASONS OF WE
WEREN'T WE WEREN'T WORKING
RATHER THAN HAVING SAID THAT WE
REALLY DO HAVE TO DO THE HARD
WORK OF DEVELOPING A SKILLED
WORKFORCE AND I APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND- THANK YOU SIR WELL
SAID IN THE COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. I SEE NINE. A SYRUP. IT
WAS WELL SET UP IT WAS WELL
SAID- AND I KNOW YOU MENTIONED.
THE FACT OF THE FOUR YEAR. GOING
ON TO A FOUR YEAR BUT IS THERE
ARE TALKS ABOUT. THE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING AT AN EARLY AGE I MEAN.
WE HEARD- K. THROUGH TWELVE BUT
THE I'M TALKING LIKE I'M TALKING
LIKE THAT THE SENIORS FOLKS THAT
I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT WE'VE WE
CHANGE CAREER SO MANY TIMES
RIGHT I MEAN I WOULD EXPECTED ME
TO BE HERE RIGHT WELL I MEAN
THAT NEVER DID I EXPECT YEAH.
RIGHT CHANGE CAREERS. CAREERS
ARE BEING CHANGED STUDENTS
NOWADAYS ARE NEVER WHO EVER
THOUGHT OF GOING INTO THE ACT.
BUT THEY WILL THINK ABOUT TECH
RIGHTRIGHT SO I'M THINKING HOW
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE ENGAGE THAT
ON A VOCATIONAL LEVEL. THAT'S
ONE QUESTION SHELDON. YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER TO YOU KNOW
WHAT STATE WHAT'S WHAT CAN THE
STATE. DO TO TARGET THE FUNDING
. NOW FOR THAT NOT LATER NOW
WELL I THINK I THINK THE STATE
IS ALREADY DOING A LOT OF TRIPS
TERRIFIC THINGS FOR INSTANCE I
HAD A CHANCE TO VISIT WITH KAREN
YESTERDAY AND I KNOW I KNOW
THEY'RE STARTING TO BE DOLLARS
AVAILABLE SPECIFICALLY FOR
FARMWORKERS I THINK THAT'S-
TERRIFIC- I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY QUESTION YOU ALL. WILL GET
GREAT- ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE TO TARGET.
EDUCATE EDUCATIONAL DOLLARS BUT
BUT I WOULD TAKE VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY. HOW DO WE START- YANG
BUT TO YOUR POINT. OUR CURRENT
WORK FORCE- AND UPSKILLING A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND LABOUR
DOLLARS AN APPRENTICESHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. WE NEED TO BE ALL
OVER THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
EXPAND THE PRODUCTIVE LIVES OF
OUR CURRENT WORKFORCE WHERE
WHERE WHERE WE CAN'T AND THESE
TYPES OF JOBS ALSO WILL LEAD TO
. BETTER WORKING IT OUT BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS AND HIGHER
WAGES. AS AS WELL BUT YEAH
YOU'RE RIGHT WE'RE ON IT WE'RE
ON KIND OF A LIFELONG. JR
LEARNING TRACK THAT I MEAN I
SUSPECT AT SOME LEVEL WE'RE ALL
WAKING UP AND I UNDERSTAND AND
I'M NOT THAT'S WHY THESE RURAL
pCOLLEGES ARE PRETTY. ARE REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL BECAUSE IT THEY
ARE THE PLACE YOU CAN MAKE THE
CONNECTION THAT YOU KNOW IS
BROADBAND COMES INTO PLAY HERE.
PEOPLE HAVE GOT MORE USED OF
WORKING ONLINE. AND YOU KNOW IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SAN JOAQUIN-
ABOUT YOU KNOW AND I MEAN I
BEGAN TO APPRECIATE IT A LITTLE
BIT MORE AS A MAYOR BECAUSE YOU
CAN ALWAYS HEAR TWENTY EIGHT
CITIES AND HOW DOES THAT WORK
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET OVERSIGHT
SPENDING TIME AND SEE. HOW THAT
REGION FUNCTIONS BUT YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE WORKING AND RELATE. YOU
KNOW YOU MIGHT YOU MIGHT GO
HOME. HELLO MORE SOMEWHERE ELSE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO
BACK TO THAT SOMEWHERE. WHAT AT
NIGHT IF RIDLEY HAPPEN YOU CAN
DO IT ONLINE SO I THINK THIS
ISSUE OF ACCESSIBILITY. IN TERMS
OF EDUCATION LIFELONG LEARNING
AND A REAL REAL FOCUS ON CURRENT
WORK FORCE. IS IMPORTANT I BUT I
ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE. YOU KNOW
WITH WITH BROADLY KNOW WHAT TO
DO THE ISSUE BECOMES ARE WE
DOING IT ON SCALE ON A
SUSTAINABLE BASIS. REALLY YOU
KNOW IT'S THE SO IT'S STRUCTURE
SCALE. SUSTAINABILITY SPILLED AT
THE SENSIBILITY OF NUMBERS
ENOUGH. I'LL GIVE YOU A VERY
SIMPLE EXAMPLE WHEN I WAS THE
MAYOR. WE HAD- YEAH WE HAD SOME
YOUTH VIOLENCE CHALLENGES IN THE
CITY AND WE WANT TO THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB AND THEY WERE GOING
TO GO INTO A DIFFERENT ZIP CODE.
AND THEY COULD SERVICE FOUR
HUNDRED. CATS OF LIKE WHAT'S
GREAT I GOT SIX THOUSAND
TEENAGERS IN THAT ZIP CODE. THE
SERVICE FOUR HUNDRED WE KNEW
WHAT TO DO. BUT IT WASN'T
SUFFICIENT. SCALE ON BANDWIDTH
SO I'M I'M KIND OF A- I MEAN I'M
REALLY BULLISH ON THIS IDEA OF.
NOT JUST STRATEGY GET NUMBERS
AROUND. AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE
CAPACITY WHAT'S THE DEMAND THEM
AND UNDERSTAND THAT BUT BUT I
THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
WORKFORCE EXTENDING A PRODUCTIVE
LIFE GET UP I THINK. YOU'VE GOT
THE PROGRAMS IN PLACE THINGS
LIKE APPRENTICESHIPS BUT I'LL
TELL YOU THE ONE THING I WOULD
REALLY TAKE VERY VERY SERIOUSLY
THERE'S GONNA BE A TEACHER ISSUE
. THE PROPOSAL IS GOING TO TEACH
THE STUFF AND I GREW TO AND THAT
AND THAT I THINK THAT'S GOT TO
BE ADDRESSED AND YEAH THAT IS NO
REFLECTION ON THE TEACHING
RECORD IN PLACE IT'S JUST. THE
JOBS OF TOMORROW OR THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW. HE ALSO HAS A LIVES
ARE GONNA REQUIRE NEW SKILLS AS
ANY I DON'T HAVE GOOD TASTE
FOCUS ON RETRAINING FOR EXAMPLE
ALSO ARE ALREADY IN THE CAREER
YEAH. IN THE MID CAREER RIGHT
YEAH AND FRANKLY I THINK A LOT
OF TEACHERS WOULD BE EXCITED TO
DO SOMETHING NEW. YOU KNOW SO IT
THAT IF SAME PER. COULD APPLY
THERE. YOU KNOW YOU KNOW IT'S
HELPFUL. TO GET FOLKS WHO ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE TERRAIN. THEN
CAN WE GET THEM EXCITED ABOUT
THE WEATHER TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES OR WHAT WE NEED TO DO
BUT IT DOES TEACHING THING. IS
REALLY A BIG BIG DEAL AND IF I
HAD TO. IMPRESS AT THE SOMETHING
UPON THE AUDIT THAT BE SOMETHING
I WOULD. ONE OF THEM. SENIOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MAYOR OKAY
YOU BET RIGHT. NEXT WE HAVE-
MICHAEL MILLER DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS. THIRTY YOU'RE DOING.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WOULD YOU
PREFER THAT I TOOK MY MASCOT TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND MAYOR. DOES IT
MATTER TO YOU. OKAY UP SEVEN A
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS- TAKE A
CHAIR- MEMBERS AND STAFF STAFF
CAN BE THIS IMPORTANT HEARING HI
MY NAME IS MICHAEL MILLER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BUYING GROUP GROWERS- AND WE'LL
TALK TODAY SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY. AND ONE COMMODITY
THAT IS WINE GRAPES- IN ABOUT
THE ISSUES THAT WE FACE AND- WE
BEGIN WHICH IS GIVING A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT OUR INDUSTRY OTHERS
MORE THAN SIX A SIX THOUSAND
MARGARET GROWERS PRODUCE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED TEN VARIETIES
CALIFORNIA'S ABA'S. MIKE GIPSON
WROTE ON SIX SEVEN EIGHT ACRES
IN FORTY NINE OF FIFTY
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES WE BELIEVE
ALMOST ALL OF YOUR COUNTIES HAVE
MY GRAPES. ABOUT SIX AN EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION GALLONS. OF WINE TO
PRODUCE A CALIFORNIA ANNUALLY.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCES AS EIGHTY
FIVE. OF ALL U. S. WHY IN
CALIFORNIA'S WINE IN MY GROUP
SECTOR EMPLOYS THREE ARE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. THE
PACE SEVENTY POINT TWO BILLION
IN WAGES ANNUALLY IF A SEVEN
POINT SIX BILLION IN TAXES AND
GENEROUS EVERY WEAPON TWO
BILLION AND ANNUAL ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY WHAT TRACK THE ONE
TWENTY THREE BILLION TOURIST
EVERY YEAR IN CALIFORNIA. U. S.
WINE EXPORTS REACHED ONE POINT
FOUR SIX BILLION IN VALUE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND 95% OF U.
S. EXPORT OF WINE COMES FROM THE
GOLDEN STATE CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
SAY CALPERS ICONIC WINE INDUSTRY
IS PROUD OF OUR RICH HERITAGE.
AND A CONTRIBUTIONS THIS AMAZING
STATE AND OUR NATION. WITH THAT
IN MIND THIS MORNING I'LL
DISCUSS TWO ISSUES RELATIVE TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF TECHNOLOGY. IN
CALIFORNIA'S WINE INDUSTRY.
FIRST ALL DISCUSSED THE NEED TO
SHIFT TO MORE AUTOMATION AND
MECHANISATION IN VINEYARD
MANAGEMENT. AND THEY'LL DISCUSS
THE CHALLENGES AROUND MAKING
THAT SHIFT. FIRST TO UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO SHIFT TO AUTOMATION
AND MCAT AND MECHANIZATION NEED
TO CAREFULLY LOOK AT OUR
EXISTING WORKFORCE CHALLENGES.
THERE COULD BE NO QUESTION THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VINEYARDS WORKFORCE
IS SHRINKING. AND ANNUAL SURVEY
VIDEO OWNERS 54% WAS A LABOR
SHORTAGE AND COST IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES TWENTY
TWENTY. AND TWENTY NINETEEN
LABOR SHORTAGE ACROSS WERE
NUMBER ONE OVERALL CONCERN FOR
WHITE GRAPE GROWERS. THERE'S
SEVERAL REASONS FOR THAT CONCERN
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS IS
NOT AN ISSUE OF A SHORTAGE OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS. ANY ASSERTION
OF THAT FAILS TO RECOGNIZE DATA
AND FACTS. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
NORTH COAST BEEN YEARS THIS YEAR
PAID AS MUCH AS THIRTY DOLLARS
PER HOUR DURING HARVEST. AND
THEY STILL CANNOT FIND ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO DO THE WORK. THAT'S
THE PUBLIC TO SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ANNUAL
SALARY. ADDITIONALLY COMPETITION
FOR LABOR FROM OTHER INDUSTRIES
IS A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE. MANY
PEOPLE JUST DON'T WANT TO WORK
IN AGRICULTURE ANYMORE MANY AG
WORKERS CAN FIND EMPLOYMENT IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES WHERE THE WORK
IS LESS DEMANDING. PHYSICALLY
DEMANDING WE CAN ALSO SEE A
SHORTAGE WE ALSO SEASHORES A
SEASONAL LABOR DUE TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICIES AND THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
H. TWO A. GUEST ADVOCATE
PROGRAM. FOR MOST OF OUR GROWERS
THAT PROGRAM IS TOO EXPENSIVE
AND IT'S A BIT CANNOT AFFORD
IT'S JUST NOT REALISTIC. BUT FOR
THOSE BUT FOR THOSE GROCERY
CAPITA TO PAY. THOSE EMPLOYERS
PROVIDE FREE TRANSPORTATION FREE
HOUSING COMPARED OF BENEFITS AND
WAGES. AND DO ALL THAT TO
ATTRACT EMPLOYEES ANOTHER
CHALLENGE FOR EMPLOYEES OF THE
VINEYARDS ARE OFTEN
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED SITUATED
ERRORS ARE TOO EXPENSIVE FOR
CRYSTAL THEM. IN A COMMUNITY
KEEP IN MIND THE VINEYARDS ARE
RURAL INDUSTRY AND OFTEN AND NOT
CLOSE TO POPULATION CENTERS.
THIS B. AS A REPLACEMENT DRIVE
LONG DISTANCES TO GET TO WORK IS
WELL DOCUMENTED THAT TOO MANY
AGGRAVATE OVERCROWDED HOUSING.
THE THEY CANNOT FIND OF HOUSING
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO THEY
SCRAMBLE INTO THE BEST THEY CAN.
WITH THIS REALITY IN MIND MANY
GROWERS WANT TO HELP AB WORKERS
BY PROVIDING HOUSING FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES. BUT THIS IS A
UNBELIEVABLY CHALLENGING ISSUE
IN CALIFORNIA THIS CALIFORNIA
LAW MAKES INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
TO BUILD HOUSING. MORE RECENTLY
COVERED RESTRICTIONS FOR HOUSING
TREAT A HOUSE LIKE A WORKPLACE
MAKING IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE HOUSING. DISCOLORATIONS
DON'T RECOGNIZE AN EMPLOYER
PROVIDED HOUSING IS INSPECTED
ANNUALLY IS SAFE AND AS HEALTHY
. WHERE THE STATE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
EMPLOYERS AND INDUSTRY TO
PROVIDE HOUSING THE STATE HAS
INSTEAD MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT.
LABOR SHORTAGES THAT THE ENTIRE
PROBLEM ANOTHER CONSIDERATION OF
FACTORS TECHNOLOGY IS INCREASING
SIZE OF CALIFORNIA VINEYARDS.
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA VINEYARD
IS APPROACHING CLOSE TO TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY ACRES IN SIZE.
YOUR THE TIME CONSTRAINTS OF A
GREAT OF THE PRODUCTION THESE
BUSINESS CANNOT PRACTICALLY BE
MANAGED WITH LABOR MANUAL LABOR
ALONE. IS ALSO INTERESTING TO
NOTE THE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THE
MECHANIZATION OF MEDICATIONS
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THE
GRAPES. AND THE CONSISTENCY OF
THE GREAT FROM BLOCK TO BLOCK
WITHIN THE VINEYARD. SO THE NEED
IS CLEAR WE NEED TO MOVE TOWARDS
GREATER USE OF TECHNOLOGY IN
VINEYARDS. THAT FACT IS WITHOUT
QUESTION. THEREFORE LET ME
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES. IN
MAKING THE SHIFT TO AUTOMATION
AND MECHANISATION. THE
MECHANIZATION CALIFORNIA
VINEYARDS BEGAN MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS AGO WITH THE CHEMICAL
HARVESTING GRAPES TODAY 90% OF
CALIFORNIA'S VINEYARDS ARE
MECHANICALLY HARVESTED AND
THERE'S BEEN A MAJOR FOCUS OF
MECHANIZATION. HOWEVER
HARVESTING IS JUST THE START.
COMING TO MAKE IT AS PRACTICES
CAN ALSO INCLUDE PRUNING SHOOT
THINNING BASIL LEAF REMOVAL
HEDGING AND PRE HARVEST CROP
REMOVAL. 65% OF VINEYARDS ARE
MECHANICALLY PRE PROVEN WELL
OTHER PRACTICES DO NOT USE AS
MUCH MECHANIZATION FOR EXAMPLE
ONLY 45% OF VINEYARDS HAVE
MECHANIZED LEAF REMOVAL 7% HAVE
MECHANIZED SHOOTING. ONLY 7% OF
VINEYARDS HAVE FRUIT REMOVAL
ONLY 2% OF IN YEARS HI SHOOT
POSITIONING. RAP ADVANCES IN
MACINNES OF ALSO OCCUR DUE TO
THE COEVOLUTION OF MACHINES BY
TRADING SYSTEMS AND BEEN YOUR
DESIGN. THIS IS SPONSORING THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF INTEGRATED
PRODUCTION SYSTEMS. CURRENT
MECHANIZATION RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA IS FOCUSED ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AUTOMATED CROP
LOAD MANAGEMENT TECHNIQUES
UTILIZING SENSORY TECHNOLOGY
SIMULTANEOUSLY MEASURE AND
MANAGE CANOPY AND CROPSCIENCE.
PLEASE REMEMBER THOUGH THAT THE
CUSTOMISATION IS NOT CHEAP FOR
SOME GROWERS IT COULD TAKE FIVE
TO TEN YEARS TO PAY OFF THAT
INVESTMENT. KEEP IN MIND THAT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA FARMERS WITH BONE
YARDS BEHIND THE SHOP FEEL WITH
THE BENCHES THAT JUST DIDN'T
WORK OUT OVER A COMPLETE LOSS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A COST OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
THAT TECHNOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU'RE MOVING FROM DIESEL TO
ELECTRIC THAT MEANS UPGRADING
YOUR LEFT WILL CHARGING CAPACITY
THIS MAY INCLUDE SOLAR PANELS
AND POWER STORAGE THIS COULD
ALSO INCLUDE GENERATORS THAT
COULD BE USED IN REMOTE AREAS.
THIS ALSO MEANS SERVICING THE
NEW ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT SOME
ROADS WE NEED A HIGHER ELECTRIC
MOTOR MECHANICS OR TECHNICIANS
VERSES TRADITIONAL DIESEL
MECHANICS. ADDITIONALLY IF A
GIRL WANTS TO RETROFIT AN
EXISTING TRACTOR TO BECOME A
THOMAS THIS IS A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF THE HARDWARE TO DO
THAT AND THEN I'M GOING ANNUAL
PAYMENT OF THE SOFTWARE THIS
QUICKLY GETS IN THE TENS. OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER TRACTOR
. ON THE PLUS SIDE THOUGH
MECHANIZATION REDUCE THE DEMAND
FOR LABOR. WHEN A GROWER SPACE
OF NOT ENOUGH A PLACE TO DO THE
WORK MECHANIZATION CAN BE A
LIFESAVER. MECHANICAL PUTTING
FOR EXAMPLE A LUMINOUS A DAY FOR
LABOR BY AS MUCH AS EIGHTY
PERCENT. MECHANICAL PUTTING
COULD SAVE BETWEEN 6280% OF
LABOR OPERATION COST PER ACRE.
COMPARED TO MANUAL PRUNING.
HOWEVER THIS IS JUST DOT THIS IS
NOT JUST ACROSS ISSUE WE ALSO
CREATING HIGHER PAYING JOBS.
WITH MECHANIZATION WITH ON THE
JOB TRAINING AND THE CONDITION
OF TECHNOLOGY EMPLOYERS HAVE
INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES TO GET
THE NECESSARY SKILLS. FOR THOSE
HIGHER PAYING POSITIONS.
EMPLOYERS CAN CLIMB THE LADDER
WITHIN AGRICULTURE. WHICH A
JUDICIAL IT KEPT UP EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM MAY NOT A PROVIDER FOR
THEM. IS ALSO INTERESTING TO
NOTE. THE MECHANIZATION CAN
INCREASE THE INCOME OF THE
WORKER. KEEP IN MIND THE GRAPES
TAKE THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME TO
MANAGE REGARDLESS OF THE MOTIVE
MANAGEMENT. WELL WITH
MECHANIZATION A GIRL CAN GET
MORE DONE WITH FEWER PEOPLE.
THOSE EMPLOYERS ARE GETTING MORE
HOURS WITH GREATER INCOME.
CONSEQUENTLY WITH THE DECLINING
AG WORKFORCE MECHANIZATION MEANS
LESS LABOR INTENSIVE WORK. AND
HIGHER LEVELS OF INCOME. MEG IS
CAN ALL BE USED TO KEEP
EMPLOYEES SAFE FOR EXAMPLE
GROWERS CAN USE REMOTE OPERATED
IRRIGATION CONTROLS TO TURN OFF
AND ON WATER MONITOR VINEYARD
HEALTH THROUGH MULTI SPECTRAL
IMAGERY WITH DRONES. NEWS MCAT
MECHANIZED HARVEST TO LIMIT THE
EXPOSURE OF EMPLOYEES DURING
SITUATIONS A BETTER QUALITY.
HOWEVER THERE'S STILL A
TREMENDOUS NEED TO PREPARE AG
EMPLOYERS FOR WORKPLACE THAT
DEMANDS HIGHLY SKILLED
EXPERIENCED WORKERS WHO CAN MAKE
THE ON. THE KIND OF ON THE SPOT
DECISION THE MACHINES CARE ACT
FOR THIS EMPLOYEES NEED TO BE
TRAINED IN THE TECHNOLOGY.
CONSEQUENTLY THERE IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR CAREER TECH
TRAINING NEED TO ENCOURAGE
COMMUNITY COLEGE PROGRAMS IN A
PRESSURE PROGRAMS THE TRAIN THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S AT WORK
FORCE. MORE THAN A DECADE OF
RESEARCH HAS CONDUCTED WAS
CONDUCTED AND WHY GREAT
VICTIMIZATION PROPER EXTENSION
UC DAVIS PART OF THE CULTURE AND
ANALOGY IS REPORT FINDING
THERE'S STILL A NEED FOR GROWERS
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND. HOW TO
MAXIMIZE THE VALUE OF THAT
MECHANIZATION. WITH ALL THIS IN
MIND I HAVE TO SAY THAT THE
FUTURE MECHANIZATION AND
AUTOMATION ENGINEERS MUST
INCLUDE A THOMAS TRACTORS AND
UTILIZATION OF THAT TECHNOLOGY.
THE CHALLENGE HERE THOUGH IS
THAT A CALIFORNIA THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS VIRTUALLY
UNAVAILABLE DUE TO REGULATORY
ROADBLOCKS. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN OUR EFFORTS TO PROTECT
OUR ENVIRONMENT. THE SOME
CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS ARE
DECADES BEHIND THE ADVANCES IN
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY. ALSO
BELIEVE THOSE REGULATIONS SERVE
AS A ROADBLOCK. TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE CALLOUS
CHEATING OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
. FOR EXAMPLE CAL OSHA REQUIRES
THAT THERE MUST BE AN EMPLOYEE
PHYSICALLY ON BOARD ANY OF
THOMAS TRACTOR. IN THE AGE OF
REMOTE CONTROL SPACE FLIGHT THIS
REGULATION SEEMS UNINFORMED AND
NONSENSICAL. TWENTY NINE STATES
HAVE ALREADY PASSED LEGISLATION
RELATING TO THE SAFE USE OF ON
THE ROAD TESTING OF AUTONOMOUS
CARS AND TRUCKS. SOME OF THE
STATE'S ALLOW USE OF THE VEHICLE
WITH NO DRIVER ON BOARD. JUST
THIS MORNING THE TODAY ISSUED A
REPORT ON THE SCIENCE AND USE OF
AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS IN RETAIL AND
FREIGHT. DRIVERLESS CARS AND
TRUCKS ARE CLEARLY IN OUR FUTURE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD. AND
EXCELLING TODAY'S AUTONOMOUS
TRACTORS SURVEY. THIS FEATURE A
VARIETY OF SAFETY PERPETRATORS
THERE WERE PROVEN TRACK RECORD
OF SAFETY. THERE DOZENS OF USES
FOR THIS TECHNOLOGY INCLUDING
THE ABILITY TO ANALYZE MOISTURE
LEVELS. ASSESSED PEST PRESSURE
COMPOSTERS AND PERFORM OTHER
CRUCIAL FUNCTIONS. IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT MANY DISTRACTORS
ARE ELECTRIC WILL RUN LIKE A TEN
PLUS HOURS. THIS EQUIPMENT IS
ZERO EMISSIONS AS A GREAT TOOL
IMPRECISE PEST CONTROL EFFORTS
AND WATER CONSERVATION. I K. AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES AWAY FROM
DIESEL FARM EQUIPMENT AND ALL
SCHOOL TECHNOLOGY. ONE DRAWER
DESCRIBE THE ATOMIC STRUCTURES
QUOTE THE MYSTIC LAKE AND THE
SUSTAINABLE CYCLE. IF I LEAVE
YOU WITH A CLEAR TAKEAWAY FROM
TODAY'S HEARING PLEASE CONSIDER
THE FOLLOWING. WE CAN SAVE WATER
BY USING THIS TECHNOLOGY TO
MEASURE WHEN AND WHERE
IRRIGATION IS NEEDED. WE CAN
REDUCE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT BY
MOVING FROM DIESEL TO ELECTRIC.
WE CAN REDUCE THE USE OF
PESTICIDES THEY USE THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO CLOSELY MONITOR
PEST ISSUES AND PRECISELY
RESPOND. WE CAN HELP GROW
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY USING
TECHNOLOGY SOME OF WHICH IS VERY
FACTUAL RATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO INCREASE OUR YIELDS. IF WE
TRULY WANT TO HELP CALIFORNIA
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE A PROTECT
OUR ENVIRONMENT. LET'S REMOVE
THE UNNECESSARY REGULATORY
ROADBLOCKS THE FULL UTILIZATION
OF OUR CURRENT TECHNOLOGY. THOSE
REGULATIONS ALSO SERVE AS A
ROADBLOCK. THE CALIFORNIA'S
SUSTAINABILITY. DILEMMAS ARISE
AS THE WAY THE SUMMER THE USE OF
CAL. THIS OF MECHANISATION.
CALIFORNIA VINEYARDS. INCLUDING
A TOWN PHARMICA IS. THE FOR
SISTER AG INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATION IS A CRITICAL PILLAR
OF CALIFORNIA'S AG FUTURE. BUT
WE STILL NEED SOME HELP
SPECIFICALLY. WE NEED TO FIX THE
OSHA REGULATION WHICH I
DISCUSSED A BIT AGO. WE ALSO
NEED TO CONTINUE FUNDING EFFORTS
TO DEVELOP TECHNOLOGY THEY'LL
HELP DISPOSE OF OLD VINES
WITHOUT BURNING THEM. THIS IS A
HUGE ISSUE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND WILL BE ALSO FOR THE
STATE. ADDITIONALLY WE NEED HELP
TO SUPPORT UNIVERSAL CALIFORNIA
UC EXTENSION CSU AND THE EFFORTS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION ABOUT
RESEARCHING THE TECHNOLOGY.
TRAINING OF WORKERS. AND
EDUCATING THE INDUSTRY. BY LATE
WHEN IT SUPPORT TECH TRAINING TO
PREPARE AG EMPLOYEES FOR NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT OUR CULTURE.
SOME NONPROFITS OF FILLING THIS
VOID THROUGH PENSION PROGRAMS
BUT THEY ARE FACED. WITH THE
BURDENSOME AND UNNECESSARY
REGULATION THAT REQUIRES THEM TO
REGISTER AS A FARM LABOR
CONTRACTOR. AGAIN THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS OF STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR SUPPORT HEARING AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
QUESTIONS FROM BOARD. H. COOPER
THANK YOU MICHAEL FOR PRISON IT
WAS VERY INFORMATIVE- YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE VINES OF THE OLD VINES
THEY'RE STACKED UP ALTHOUGH A
RECENT TOUR DOWN THE VALLEY AND
I SAW STACKS AND STACKS OF OLD
LINE'S BEEN TORN UP AS WELL AS
TREES BECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE A
CERTAIN LIFE SPAN THEY DON'T
LAST FOREVER NOT FOREVER THEY
KEEP STACKING UP AND THAT'S
REALLY BEEN A BIG ISSUE FOR YOU
THE WINEGROWERS WELLS OTHER CROP
GROWERS. AND WE'VE YOU GUYS ARE
GETTING NO RELIEF FROM- KELLY P.
AIR I'M SORRY CARB SO WE DID GET
SOME FUNDING THE BUDGET FOR THE
ENSEMBLE CARE BOARD TO DEVELOP
TECHNOLOGIES TO WORK WITH US AND
THEN RESOLVE THIS PROBLEM THEY
HAVE SOME GRANT PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO HELP GROWERS IN THE
SHORT TERM BUT THE LONG TERM WE
STILL TO COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS
TO DEAL WITH- WITH WHAT WE DO
TAKE OUT OF AND I'LL SPEAK TO
THE VENUE PART OF IT- THE OTHER
PROVIDERS HAVE ISSUES AS WELL.
BUT REMEMBER WHEN YOU TAKE OUT A
VINEYARD THE VINEYARD HAS HAS
SHOP LIKE A TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
YEARS WHATEVER IT IS AND NOW
IT'S NOT PRODUCING ANYMORE WHEN
YOU TAKE IT DOWN YOU TAKE OUT
EVERYTHING THAT'S PART OF IT SO
ALL OF THAT METAL THAT IS THOSE
INSIDE THE BANK COMES DOWN AND
YOU CAN'T PULL IT OUT OF THE-
OUT OF OUT OF OUT OF THE BY
BECAUSE IT'S TOO LABOR INTENSIVE
SO ALL THAT GOES INTO A BIG
STACK. YOU CAN'T BE A CHIP THAT
YOU CAN'T BECAUSE OF THE METAL
AND IT YOU CAN'T BURN IT BECAUSE
WERE MOVING QUITE ACT BURN SO
THAT LEAVES YOU WITH VERY FEW
OPTIONS AND WE NEED TO REALLY
PURSUE A SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM
SOLUTION TO THAT CHALLENGE AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT BUT WE
HAVE THREE YEARS BASICALLY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
WITH THOSE VINEYARDS AND IT'S A
BIG. ISSUE DISTRICTS. I YOU.
SELECT THANK VERY MUCH OF A MR
MILLER- WAS A STRICT TO COME HE
MADE WITH WITH RESPECT HOUSING
AND ISSUE THE IMPACT THE WORK
FOR BUT ASK YOURS TO SEE IF THEY
CAN SO OF ONE GROWERS- TAKE-
EFFORTS TO HELP ADVOCATE FOR A
NUMBER OF THE HOUSING
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAD IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PREVIOUS
YEARS WE HAVE ACTUAL WORK
CLOSELY WITH- THIS IS YOUR CURRY
WAS SENATOR DODD- TWO OR THREE
DIFFERENT HOUSING BILLS PLUS WE
WORKED WITH THE- CAL OSHA ON
THEIR PROGRAMS TO DO WITH HOW
YOU TREAT THE OF THE- THE
HOUSING SITUATION WHERE IT'S A
PART OF OUR HOUSING RELATIVE TO
WORKPLACE SAFETY THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SO EVEN. IF THE PUTTING
ASIAN APPROACH AND THAT AND THAT
AND THAT WILL DISCUSS OF GREAT
IN THE STORE THEN CONTINUE LEAD
TO BE ADVOCATING FOR A NUMBER OF
HOUSING BILLS- TO THE LET ME
VERY MUCH LIKE THAT YES IT'S
GREAT AND THEN THE OTHER- POINT
THAT YOU MADE WAS- WITH FACT TO
A TONS VEHICLES- AND YOU
REFERENCED A POINT THAT THAT
MANY OF THE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
HOME GROWN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS VERY TRUE TO. HAVE YOU
BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
OTHER ENTITIES TO HELP ADVOCATE
TO BEGIN THE FRAME WORK TO HELP
SUPPORT SUCH TECHNOLOGIES AS WE
WERE WORKING MORE WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS DIRECTLY OKAY BUT
IT TO ANY WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO
HAVE ANY OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
THE REASON I ASK IS BECAUSE I
I'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
SOME OF THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES
ALSO IN SILICON VALLEY AND TO
HEAR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT
OF THAT AS WELL I THINK TO HELP
AMPLIFY THE MESSAGE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING THE
TECHNOLOGY HERE. OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS MET JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO WE DISCUSSES A SHOW LIKE IS
ONE OF OUR HIGHEST PRIORITIES AT
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND WE ARE
ENGAGED AND. ARE VERY HELPFUL.
OBESITY IS A THAT YOU HAVE YEAH
ONE'S GOING THAT I GET THAT
THAT'S NOT. BEEN OF HAVING THIS
HEARING TO. BECAUSE I DIDN'T I
IT WAS MADE AWARE THAT THE- THIS
. HAVE THIS IS A TWO PRIORITY
WELL TO AN- OF COURSE. A NUMBER
OF THE- MANY IN THE INDUSTRY.
ARE LOOKING AT OTHER STATES IN
WHICH THEY'RE ROLLING OUT THE
RED CARPET IN SAYING HERE. THE
RULES RAGS AND DOES NOT BEEN.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'VE ANTICIPATED BUT- IT
JUSTICE BGGLES OUR MIND THAT WE
MIGHT NOT SUPPORT THAT HERE
GIVEN ITS- HOME GROWN
TECHNOLOGIES. THAT COULD AGREE
MORE EFFORT FOR WINE GRAPES AND
BEING. WE ARE ABLE. IN YOU KNOW
INDUSTRY WE COMPETE WITH. I
THINK WE'RE THE FIFTH LARGEST
CALIFORNIA'S THE FIFTH LARGEST
WINE PRODUCER. IN THE WORLD
RIGHT NOW COMPARED TO. ITALY
FRANCE SPAIN- SUBIN. IT IS A
HUGE ISSUE FOR US YES I AGREE.
GREAT THANK YOU. THEN JUST ONE
MORE THING THOSE JURISDICTIONS
DON'T. FACE THE SAME CONSTRAINTS
WE FACE YOU FACE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BE TO BE MORE
BROADLY CLEAR NOW DON'T THE SAME
CONSTRAINTS WE FACE. OFTENTIMES
THOSE COUNTRIES AT THE ACTUALLY
SUBSIDIZE THE INDUSTRY BIGGER
MARKETING MONEY FROM- FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEY GET THE
SYSTEM TO RESEARCH THAT
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T GET. AND IT'S
A BIG COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE
TRUST THAT'S THAT ARE ONE IS THE
BEST IN THE NATION PLEASE PLEASE. MISTER RODRIGUEZ. THANK
MICHAEL THANK YOU MEANT OF SURE
PRESENTE AND I THINK THE FUTURE
IS BRIGHT WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
WHAT WE'LL BE LOOKING AT IN THE
FUTURE BUT I JUST WANTED TO
TOUCH BASE ON SOME YOU TALK
ABOUT REAL BRIEFLY IN THE
OPENING REMARKS REGARDING LABOR
ARE IN REGARDS TO H. TWO A. VISA
HOLDERS IN THE REASON WHY I SAY
THIS IDEA DID WAS PICKING UP
SOME LEGISLATION AROUND THAT AND
I DID DO A- A RIGHT ALONG WITH
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE
MY DISTRICT A COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
AND CAME ACROSS SOME OF THE- THE
WORKERS OUT THERE UNFORTUNATELY
THERE WERE H. TWO A. VISA
HOLDERS ARE WORKING IN THE AG
INDUSTRY AND- GOING BACK TO WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT THE GROUP OF
WORKERS- WHAT IS INDUSTRY DOING
TO PROTECT THOSE H. TWO A. VISA
WORKERS BECAUSE I SEEN REPORTS
THAT THOSE A GROUP OF- A CHOI
WITH BOBBY SO HOLDERS ARE THE
MOST TRAFFIC IT- IN THAT ARENA
SO WONDER WHAT WERE THE ENTRY IS
WITHOUT PROTECTING THOSE WORKERS
IN MAKING SURE THAT GETTING THE
SUPPORT IN AND RESOURCES THEY
NEED THAT THEY'RE NOT OUT THERE
BEING DRAFTED. AS I'VE SEEN AND
I SHE REPORTS SO JUST WANTED
PICKING BACK ON THIS ENTRY
BROUGHT IT UP AT THE BEGINNING
I'M HAPPY TO SET US UP FOR THE
FOR THE WINE GRAPE INDUSTRY-
AGENCE ADDITION AFFORDABILITY
SALUTE THE GROSS WHO CAN AFFORD
TO SPEND THAT PROGRAM BECAUSE
REMEMBER YOU HAVE TO HIRE LEGAL
TEAM YOU HAVE TO REACH FOR
TRANSPORTATION YET TO PROVIDE
FREE HOUSING THAT HAVE
COMPETITIVE WAGES AND BENEFITS
THEY'RE ABOVE YOU BELOW WHAT IS
PAID TO THE EDGE OF THE AVERAGE
AG RECURSOS. THE GROSS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM A
DIFFICULT TOWARDS THAT THE
NUMBERS RIVAS IS ON A TOUR OF
ONE OF THESE FACILITIES WE DO A
LOT OF EDUCATION WITH THEM WE'RE
CLOSE WITH THE FARM BUREAU AND
OTHER AG ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE GROWERS KNOW WHAT
IS REQUIRED THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S INSPECTED AND ALL THAT
AND THAT THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
VERY HIGH AND WHAT I CAN SAY IS
THAT IN TALKING TO BETTER THE
GROWERS AND I'VE GOT MYSELF AND
TALKED WITH THE WORKERS.
DIRECTLY THEY COME BACK YEAR
AFTER YEAR THEY'RE NOT GROWING
THEY'RE NOT FEWER WORKERS WERE
UNHAPPY IN THEIR JOB THEY COME
BACK EVERY YEAR AND THEY THEY DO
BY CHOICE THEY DON'T WANT TO
MOVE TO CALIFORNIA THEY WERE TO
COME TO CALIFORNIA PREPARED. OF
TIME THE I A STAY AT HOME. THEY
PROVIDE THE MONEY. INTO THE FOR
AT HOME. WAS A- THEIR FOR. AND
THEY HOUSING EDUCATION. BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T MAKE MONEY IN AND
THAT'S- SO. THE PROGRAM AT WORKS
FOR ALL OF THE- AND THEY DO COME
BACK. YEAR AFTER AFTER YEAR. I
TALKED TO WAS WORKERS DIRECTLY.
CAN GREAT THANK. MANORIAL
WALDRON THANK YOU REAL QUICK- AS
KNOW HAVE TO MACULA ON THE
VINEYARDS THERE- WHEN I'VE
TALKED THE GROWER IN ALL THROUGH
THE YEARS THE DEALING WITH- YOU
KNOW SOME OF THEM ARE STILL
DOING IT THE OLD WAY A LOT OF
THEM ARE TRYING TO LOOK INTO
THINGS LIKE SYSTEMIC MONITORING-
TO LOOK AT BASICALLY SOIL
PROFILES THROUGHOUT THEIR AREA
HOW MUCH WATER IS IN THE GROUND
IN ONE PLACE VERSUS ANOTHER
HUMIDITY IN THE AIR THAT CAN
EVEN. WITH THE MODERN
TECHNOLOGY. CHECK THE GRAVE
RIGHT THIS. BUT FOR THE MOST
PART THEY'RE DRIVING A TRACTOR
AROUND WITH THE PERSON IN IT
LOOKING TO CHECK. OR LOOKING FOR
MILDEW AND ROT WHICH IS A BIG
ISSUE- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GENERALLY JUST DOING SPRING
WEATHER THIS MILDURA. AT ALL.
AND I THINK TECHNOLOGY THAT IS A
HUGE AREA FOR HELP IN THAT
REGARD. BUT YOU KNOW ONCE AGAIN
WE HAVE THOSE BARRIERS ARE HOW
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO. ACCESS SAID
HOW THE GOING TO BE TRAINED TO
USE IT AND- YOU KNOW THE COST
SO. THIS IS THE COMMON. THANK
YOU SEE AREA- MISTRAL QUESTION.
ON YOUR PROFESSIONAL OPINION DO
YOU SEE TAX ELIMINATING JOBS. NO
I REALLY DON'T I SEE TECH IS
ACTUALLY CREATING JOBS FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS ONE IS. WHAT
WHAT DO YOU LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE
IN A WORKFORCE IT'S AN AGING
WORKFORCE. AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF NEW YOUNGER PEOPLE COMING
IN AND IT'S A LOT BECAUSE THEY
THEY THEY CAN GET. LESS
PHYSICALLY DEMANDING JOBS AND
OTHER INDUSTRIES OKAY. AT THE
SAME TIME THEIF YOU WANT TO
TRACK THOSE NEW EMPLOYEES INTO
THIS INDUSTRY AND WORKING IN A
IN A VINEYARD. GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO ONE IS A TRANSFERABLE
SKILL WHICH IS YET TECHNOLOGY IF
YOU'RE IF YOU REMOTE CONTROL
OPERATING OF MACHINERY YOU'RE OR
YOU'RE ANALYZING. ENTIRE VENUE
FOR THE- IRRIGATION ISSUES PAST
ISSUES OR WHATEVER. YOU'RE
LEARNING THIS TECHNOLOGY AS A
TRANSFERABLE SKILL. ON TOP OF
THAT IF YOU'RE DOING THIS IN
THAT USINESS THIS UPWARD
MOBILITY WITHIN IT THAT BEARD
OPERATION. SO IF ANYTHING I SEE
TECHNOLOGY AS BEING SOETHING
THAT WHILE THE TRACK RECORDS TO
AGRICULTURE BECAUSE IT'S MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM. IT'S
HIGHER PAID JOBS FOR THE
POTENTIALLY. AND IT'S LESS.
PHYSICALLY DEMANDING WORK. THIS
YEAR. BAKER IS RUNNING THANK YOU
ALL HAVE A GREAT DAY. WE ON.
NEXT WE HAVE- CLAYTON COWDEN
DEAN OF THE CAREER TECH TECH
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AT
HARTNELL COLLEGE IN SALINAS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
FOR HAVING YOU CAN HEAR ME ALL
RIGHT- AND AGAIN I'M VERY
HUMBLED TO BE HERE MY NAME'S
CLINT COWDEN AND I'M A DEAN OF A
SMALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
SALINAS- CALIFORNIA UP I WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN MY REMARKS WITH A
PERSONAL STORY THAT I HAVE THAT
I BELIEVE THIS CAPSULE IT'S KIND
OF THIS TIMELESS CONNECTION
BETWEEN AGRICULTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY AND THAT CONTINUAL
PURSUIT FOR THAT COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE. UP THIS STORY
INVOLVES MY GREAT GRANDFATHER CW
CURTIS WHO APPEARS IN A BLACK
AND WHITE PHOTO ON THE FINAL
PAGE OF THE FINAL BOOK IN THE
TIME WHITE SERIES OLD WEST. HE'S
RIDING A HORSE AND HE'S LOOKING
OVER HIS SHOULDER AT AN
AIRPLANE. THE PHOTO WAS TAKEN ON
A RANCH IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES
BACK IN WYOMING. THEN IN THE
BOOK. THAT PHOTO IS USED TO
SYMBOLIZE. THAT THE COWBOYS ARE
KIND OF LOSING THE BATTLE TO
TECHNOLOGY. BUT THE TRUTH IS
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE. MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER HAD ACTUALLY HIRED
THAT AIRPLANE TO FLY UP HIGH SO
THEY CAN CIRCLE AROUND AND LOOK
FOR STRIDES I WHEN THEY SEE
STRAYS THEY TIP THEIR WINGS AND
YOU KNOW WHERE THE CAMERA YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WRITE AROUND ALL
THE TIME. NOWADAYS IF WE MOVE
FORWARD NOWADAYS THAT'S A DRONE
THE COWBOYS PROBABLY ON A FOUR
WHEELER HE'S GOT A GPS AND THAT
INFORMATION IS BEING HOT BATCH
RIGHT BACK TO THE OFFICE. AND SO
WHEN WE REALLY LOOK AT THIS
AGRICULTURE'S DEMAND FOR
TECHNOLOGY IS A CONSISTENT FORCE
WHERE WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
HOW CAN WE REDUCE OUR INPUTS
INTO AGRICULTURE. ONE OF THOSE
INPUTS IS EDUCATION AND WE
STARTED TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY AND HOW DO WE PREPARE
THIS WORK FORCE THAT CAN DESIGN
IMPLEMENT AND OPERATE. THAT
TECHNOLOGY. AND CONTINUE TO
UPSKILL THE WORK FORCE THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP THEM IN OUR WORK
FORCE AND KEEP THEM. EVOLVING
WITH THIS RAPIDLY CHANGING
TECHNOLOGY. AT HARTNELL COLLEGE
IT IS SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO GO
OUT THERE AND COMMUNICATE NOT
ONLY WITH THE LARGE EMPLOYERS
BUT ALSO WITH THE FOLKS THAT ARE
STARTING AND CREATING THIS
TECHNOLOGY. WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. IN ORDER TO PREPARE
THE WORKFORCE. SO THAT THEY CAN
OPERATE THE EQUIPMENT THAT WE
HAVE ON THE FARM TODAY. BUT SO
THEY CAN ALSO WE'VE ALL WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY AS IT CONTINUES TO
MOVE. A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
A CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING
RIGHT NOW WITH UC SANTA CRUZ AND
SO UC SANTA CRUZ CAME OVER TO US
AND THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT HEY
LET'S CREATE. THIS DRONE
PROGRAM. AND DO WE NEED A
LICENSING THING AND WE REALLY
LOOK AT IT A DRONE A SATELLITE-
A FIXED WING AIRPLANE. IT'S
REALLY ABOUT GOING OUT THERE AND
GATHERING A LARGE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION AND THEN UTILIZING
THAT INFORMATION TO MAKE THOSE
QUALITY DECISIONS. SO WHAT WE'RE
REALLY DOING IS GOING TO ADJUST
THAT AND TRY TO RUN THAT
TECHNOLOGY ACROSS MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS SO IT'S NOT THAT
TARGETED THING OF JUST A DRONE
BUT HOW CAN WE USE THAT. SO MY
FOCUS AT HARTNELL IS HOW DO WE
DEVELOP THESE HIGHLY
SOPHISTICATED WORK FORCE. MANY
OF OUR DEGREE DEGREE SEEKING
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION.
LATINA X. FAMILIES THAT COME
FROM YOU KNOW THE FARM WORKING
WORLD. SOMETIMES THEY ARE GOING
TO SHY AWAY FROM AGRICULTURE
BECAUSE THEY'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT GOING INTO AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION. SO PART OF
OUR CHALLENGE IS HELPING THEM
SEE THIS INCREDIBLE CAREER
OPPORTUNITY THAT AWAITS THEM IN
AGTECH. AND THESE CAREERS ARE
RIGHT THERE IN THEIR BACKYARD.
NOW AND MOVING FORWARD INTO THE
FUTURE. LEARNING HOW TO
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
INCREASE EFFICIENCY AND YIELD
WHILE DECREASING IMPORTS AT THE
SAME TIME MAKING AG JOBS MORE
HIGHLY SKILLED AND MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO THE NEXT
GENERATION. FOR EXAMPLE A SELF
GUIDED TRACTOR WITH A VARIABLE
RATE APPLICATION CAN TRACK THE
INPUT APP THE INPUTS. THAT CAN
BE USED TO DETERMINE THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO APPLY THOSE
DIFFERENT INPUTS SUCH AS
FERTILIZERS. WE THEN. CAN TAKE
AND KEEP A LOG OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND SO WE TRULY
KNOW EXACTLY THAT SITE SPECIFIC
CONCEPT OF WHERE AND HOW MUCH
FERTILIZER WAS USED ON THAT FORM
AND THEN WE CAN DO ABOUT JUST
LIKE WE BALANCE OUR CHECKBOOKS
WE CAN DO THAT NUTRIENT BALANCE
RIGHT OUT THERE. THESE AND THERE
THERE'S AN ENTIRE SEGMENT OF
PLANT GENETICS FOR EXAMPLE
DEVELOPING PLANS THEY CAN STAND
UP COLLAR SO THAT THESE HARVEST
THESE AUTOMATED HARVEST MACHINES
CAN GO OUT THERE AND HARVEST. OR
WORKING WITH PLANTS THAT ARE
TRULY DESIGNED TO BE GROWN IN
CLIMATE CONTROLLED GREENHOUSES.
DRISKELL BERRIES S A LARGE-
ALYSS GROWTH AND THERE FARMING
TECHNICIANS ARE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THE GENETICS TEAM TO
REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT THOSE
QUALITIES BEST SUIT FOR THOSE
PLANTS TO BE GROWN IN THAT IN
THAT TYPE OF LOCATION.
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
REQUIRES TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
TECHNOLOGY TO IDENTIFY THE
INFESTATION AND THEN PROVIDE
JUST IN TIME AROUND AT. THE
RATIFICATION WITH THE LEAST
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT. MOST
OF ARE STILL MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS- ARE REALLY LOOKING AT
AGRICULTURE CAREERS THAT FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WE WOULDN'T EVEN I
IDENTIFY AS AGRICULTURE. THEY
WILL JOIN THE WORK FORCE IN WITH
IN WHICH MATHEMATICIANS
ENGINEERS BIOLOGISTS SALES
PRODUCTION CREWS WORK TOGETHER
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS. WE ALREADY
HAVE SEEN THIS THROUGH THE OUR
EXPANSION OF OUR INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM AT HARTNELL WHERE WE
TAKE OUR MATH STUDENTS AND
THEY'RE WORKING ON YIELD
FORECASTING FOR SPECIFIC
SOFTWARE WE'RE HAVING OUR
BIOLOGY AND CHEMISTRY STUDENTS
WORKING ON AN E. COLI GENETICS
PRODUCTS SO AGAIN GETTING THEM
IN THERE AND TRULY SEEING WHAT
THE SCIENCE. IS OUT THERE DOING. IN THE KEY WITH THE
INTERNSHIPS IS BECAUSE AS WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WITH THREE
TO FOUR HUNDRED DIFFERENT
COMMODITIES WITH. TWO HUNDRED
DIFFERENT JOB TITLES PER
COMMODITY. THAT COULD BE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF COLLEGE
CLASSES SO THESE INTERNSHIPS ARE
REALLY THIS GREAT WAY TO REDUCE
THAT CREATION OF A MYRIAD OF
COLLEGE COURSES. STUDENTS GAIN
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE IN THE
INDUSTRY IS PROVIDED A WELL
TRAINED QUALIFIED WORKFORCE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS WERE
REALLY FOCUSED ON TO TRY TO
REDUCE THE BRAIN DRAIN FROM THE
SALINAS VALLEY. MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS TO CHOOSE STEM FIELDS
DO THAT PER PACK PRECISELY
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOOKING AT THESE
OTHER AREAS. INTERNSHIPS ARE THE
APPLIED LEARNING EXPERIENCES
THAT THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN ENGINEERING
BIOTECH COMPUTER SCIENCE CAN
DISCOVER THAT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE ISN'T WHAT THEY
IMAGINE. THEY GET TO USE THEIR
THEORETICAL KNOWLEDGE IN THESE
HIGH. TECH AREAS- AND TO GET TO
WORK IN THEIR BACKYARD. THE
INTERNSHIPS ARE PAID SO THAT THE
STUDENTS CAN SCHEME CAN GAIN THE
RELATIVE SKILLS. BUT THEY ALSO
NEED TO THAT WAGE TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES. ANOTHER
IMPORTANT GROUP AND I LOVE IT
THAT THIS GROUP IS ALREADY
TOUCHING ON THIS. IS A STE THE
PEOPLE THERE ALREADY WORKING IN
OUR AG INDUSTRY. I TEND TO CALL
THOSE STUDENTS AND GRANTS IN
THAT WORLD. THE INCUMBENT
WORKERS. WE HAVE JOINED WITH
EMPLOYERS TO OFFER NON CREDIT
COURSES THAT PREPARE THAT
WORKFORCE FOR THESE NEW ROLES
AND THEIR COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO.
START TO EXPAND THEIR TECHNOLOGY
AND THEIR AUTOMATION AS THEIR
WORK FORCE GAINES THESE NEW
THESE NEW THIS NEW TRAINING.
THEY CAN TAKE THE COURSES IN THE
EVENINGS AND GAIN NEW SKILLS
THAT QUALIFY THEM FOR THESE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES. WE ARE ABLE TO
LEARN NEW THINGS SUCH AS
MECHATRONICS AND SO RIGHT NOW
OUR COLLEGES IS STARTING A BRAND
NEW MECHATRONICS PROGRAM IN
JANUARY. AND WE'VE INSTALLED A
TWO MILLION DOLLAR SMART
FACTORY. WHERE STUDENTS CAN
FOCUS ON INTEGRATED LOGISTICS
COMMUNICATION MECHATRONICS
ROBOTIC ASSEMBLY AND
TROUBLESHOOTING CAPACITIES. NOT
ONLY WAS THIS TECHNOLOGY FUNDED
BY A PRODUCE LEADER TAYLOR FARMS
THAT'S HEAD QUARTERED IN SALINAS
BUT WE ALSO TOURED A LOT OF
ADVANCED FOOD MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES MET WITH EMPLOYERS
AND REALLY FOCUSED ON WHAT IS
THE ENDGAME TO CREATE WHERE WE
WANTED TO GO. WE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED OUR TRAINING LAB IN OUR
CURRICULUM TO ADDRESS BOTH
OUTSIDE IN THE FIELD BUT ALSO IN
THE PROCESSING OF THAT FOOD. SO
STUDENTS CAN UNDERSTAND THE AGRA
NAMIK MANAGEMENT OF THE SOIL AND
THE WEATHER BUT ALSO THE
INTEGRATION OF THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE WANT TO GIVE OUR STUDENTS
THAT HANDS ON SKILLS SO THEY CAN
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING. THE
SIMPLE FACT IS MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ONCE THEY GET OUT FROM
OUR COLLEGE PROGRAMS ARE
EXPECTED TO. COME IN AND REALLY
TURN A PROFIT WITHIN THE FIRST
TWO WEEKS SO GIVING THOSE TRUE
HANDS ON SKILLS ARE SO IMPORTANT
. WE ALSO WANT TO GIVE OUR
STUDENTS GREAT UNDERSTANDINGS OF
FLUID DYNAMICS ELECTRICITY AND
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THAT CAN
HELP THEM SO THAT AS SYSTEMS
INVOLVED OVER THE NEXT FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS. THEY'RE READY TO
MEET THOSE CHALLENGES. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT. THAT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE. THAT NOT JUST OUR AG
TECH STUDENTS BUT STUDENTS
HOLISTICALLY NOW ARE REALLY
LIFETIME LEARNERS. NGUYEN THEY
MAY HAVE TAKEN THE SOILS CLASS
OR PLANT SCIENCE CLASS IN THE
PAST. BUT OVER THE LAST THREE
FIVE SEVEN YEARS SO MANY THINGS
HAVE CHANGED SO WE SEE A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS COMING BACK IN
NEEDING TO RETAKE THOSE CLASSES.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN
INTEGRATE THE TECHNOLOGY WITH
THE THEORY THAT THEY'VE USED
BEFORE AND THIS IS WHERE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS SUCH A
GREAT ADVANTAGE BECAUSE WE'RE
RIGHT THERE IN THEIR BACKYARDS-
BUT WE DO NEED TO RE EXAMINE
SOME OF THE RESTRICTIONS THE
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE. BECAUSE
MANY MANY OF OUR CLASSES ARE YOU
TAKE A ONCE AND THEN YOU'RE DONE. BUT REALLY THIS IS ALREADY
STARTING TO HAPPEN AND MOST OF
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN SAY
SIMILAR STORIES. AT HARTNELL WE
HAVE A FOOD SAFETY PROGRAM FOR
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR STUDENTS.
HAVE A BACHELORS DEGREE IN
SOMETHING LIKE AG BUSINESS OR
MICROBIOLOGY BUT BECAUSE OF A
CAREER CHANGER PIVOT THEY'RE
COMING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO UNDERSTAND. HOW DO I
DO THAT PAPERWORK WHAT AM I
GONNA EXPECT WHEN THE AUDITOR
COMES ON TO OUR ONTO OUR FARM.
AND THAT IS WHERE HARTNELL AND
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN CAN
REALLY HELP BECAUSE WE CAN COME
IN AND TEACH THOSE HARD SKILLS.
SO WHEN WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
OUR STUDENTS IT'S REALLY A
BIFURCATED APPROACH AND ONE IN
WHICH WE WANT TO EMBRACE OUR
TRADITIONAL STUDENTS THOSE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS THAT JUST
GRADUATED. BUT WE ALSO REALLY
NEED TO EMBRACE AND ATTRACT THE
ADULT STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUT THERE WORKING FOR TEN OR
FIFTEEN YEARS. THE EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN YEAR OLDS THEY NEED TO
SEE HOW THEY FIT INTO THIS
CONTINUE ON THE BACK PRODUCTION
. THE EXPERIENCE WORKERS ALREADY
UNDERSTAND THAT PART BUT THEY
NEED HOSE ADDITIONAL HARD TO
FIND SKILLS THAT WILL QUALIFY
THEM FOR THE HIGHER PAYING ROLES
AS A TECHNICIAN. OR HOW THEY CAN
INCORPORATE THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY
INTO THEIR CURRENT JOB. AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL WE'RE
EXCITED. TO MEET THESE
CHALLENGES AND WE RECOGNIZE THE
CENTRAL ROLE IN MEETING THIS
WORKFORCE NEED FOR THE AG
INDUSTRY. FIRST WE MUST WORK
EVEN HARDER TO HELP OUR STUDENTS
SEE THEMSELVES IN THIS HIGH TECH
TECHNOLOGY. AND STEPPING INTO
THESE INTO THIS FUTURE.
ACHIEVING THIS ON A LARGE SCALE
MAY REQUIRE A STATE WIDE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. NOT UNLIKE
WHAT MUST MANY OF THE RUST BELT
STATES DID FOR ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING. SECONDLY WE ARE
INCREASINGLY HELPING EMPLOYERS
SHIFT THEIR CURRENT EMPLOYEES
INTO AUTOMATED HARVESTING AND
PROCESSING AND THEN TRAINING
THEM ALL THESE DATA DRIVEN TO
DATA. DRIVEN DECISIONS AND JUST
IN TIME MANAGEMENT. AND FINALLY%
WE ARE ALSO GRAPPLING WITH THE
OTHER REALITY THAT I MENTIONED.
AG EDUCATION CAN NO LONGER BE A
ONE AND DONE THING. TECHNOLOGY
THAT COMPANIES RELY ON TODAY CAN
QUICKLY BECOME OUTDATED SO WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
PROVIDE CAREER LONG TRAINING TO
HELP WORKERS REMAIN RELEVANT.
OUR TEACHING TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WE HAVE ALSO HAVE TO KEEP UP
WITH THIS CONTINUAL IMPROVING
AND CYCLE THAT THAT
AGRICULTURE'S MOVING THROUGH. WE
KNOW THERE'S NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
HANDS ON LEARNING AND CAREER
DEVELOPMENT- BUT THAT OFTEN CAN
OCCUR IN THOSE INTERNSHIPS THAT
I'VE DISCUSSED. HOWEVER SCALING
UP THERE THE AVAILABILITY FOR
PAID INTERNSHIPS WILL REQUIRE
FUNDING AT HARTNELL COLLEGE WERE
EAGER TO SEE MORE AND MORE OF
OUR STUDENTS. PURSUING REWARDING
CAREERS IN AG TECH AND THEY'RE
CLOSE TO HOME IN ADDITION WE
WILL CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE
WITH EMPLOYERS EAGER TO SHARPEN
THEIR EXISTING WORKERS ABILITIES
TO THRIVE IN THIS RAPIDLY
CHANGING INDUSTRY. DOING THESE
THINGS WELL AND MAKING THEM ON A
LARGE SCALE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WILL REQUIRE INVESTMENT. THE L.
SO. WHAT I'M HERE TO SAY IS A
I'M HERE ASKING THE SAME THING
THAT MY GREAT GRANDFATHER DID
FROM THAT AIRPLANE PILOT AND IF
YOU GUYS CAN REALLY LOOK AT THIS
AND HELP US OUT IDENTIFY SOME OF
THOSE LOST FUNDS THANK YOU. FOR
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
I'M A BIG COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADVOCATE THEM HIGH SCHOOL-
AGRICULTURAL CLASS BECAUSE I'M
SO I ADMIRE WHAT YOU'RE DOING IT
HARD NOW- KILL OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TAP INTO YOUR CLASSES-
FOR THE CLASSES ONLINE- IN OTHER
COLLEGES COLLABORATING BECAUSE
THIS THIS IS NOT A ONE THIS IS
ALMOST NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BUT- A LOT OF THE AG TECHNOLOGY
IS KIND OF ONE SIZE- SO CAN YOU
GIVE ME SOME IDEAS WHAT YOU
MIGHT BE DOING WITH OTHER
COLLEGES IN MY RURAL. COLLEGES I
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY'RE DOING
THIS AND SO SHAME ON ME I WILL
FIND OUT BUT- DIFFERENCE THERE
THERE'S COLLABORATION VAULT AND
THAT YOU ARE BRINGING DRY DÍAS
TOGETHER BE ABLE TO DO AYE I
KNOW SOME OF THESE CLASSES COULD
BE ONLINE THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
ON THE FIELD SO. ARE YOU WILING
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION IT
YES- SO. CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES A PRETTY SMALL NETWORK-
AND SO WE WORK. REALLY CLOSELY
TOGETHER SO DENNIS WAS
DISCUSSING. KIND OF THAT
COLLABORATIVE OF REALLY KIND OF
LOOKING AT NORTH SOUTH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SALINAS. HAS
KIND OF THAT APPROACH IN THOSE
THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
MULTIPLE TIMES- A LOT OF US GET
TOGETHER WORK ON THAT WE WORK
ON. ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE DOWNSIDES WHEN THE HARD.
REALITIES OF. IT UP WITH GRANTS
. IS NUMBERS AND WHEN YOU'RE
RURAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE. YOU
JUST CAN'T HIT THE NUMBERS THAT
A LOT OF URBAN COLLEGES CAN HIT
WHEN YOU'RE APPLYING FOR A
GRANT. SO THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
REALLY BE COMPETITIVE. IS BY
WORKING TOGETHER ACROSS TO. YOU
KNOW HE DIFFERENT LINES ARE
COMPANIES. ARE THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE SO ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
WE ALL KNOW IS WE'VE GOT TO WORK
TOGETHER NO NO ONE WILL SEE
HERE- IN MY DISTRICT. I'M ONLY
GOING TO BE DOING THIS ON MY
DISTRICT I WOULD HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER- STATEWIDE THERE'S LOTS
OF DIFFERENT THINGS AND SO LIKE-
I JUST FINISHED WITH A- NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION- GRANT WHERE
WE TOOK. ALL OF OUR FOOD SAFETY
CLASSES. AND STE- PUT THOSE IN A
CANVAS CARTRIDGE SO YES THEY'RE
ONLINE. AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE USING A SOFTWARE CALLED
CAMPUS. AND SO THEY- THEY CAN
ACTUALLY JUST DOWNLOAD IT AND
UPLOAD RIGHT INTO THEIR THEIR
THEIR CLASSES. SO THE ONLY TO
RUN THAT THROUGH THEIR ACADEMIC
SENATES IN THOSE KIND OF THINGS.
WE ALSO TAKE THAT SAME
INFORMATION AND NOW THAT CAN BE
INTEGRATED RIGHT INTO THOSE HIGH
SCHOOL CURRICULA. BUT A LOT OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING AND
WE KIND OF TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER
YES. WE CAN'T WAIT UNTIL THAT
STUDENT. GRADUATES HIGH SCHOOL.
TO START THINKING ABOUT SOME OF
THESE AREAS- AND AGAIN MANY OF
OUR HIGH SCHOOL INSTRUCTORS.
THEY'RE TEACHING LIKE TWELVE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES WITHIN
AGRICULTURE RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT
TO GIVE THEM THOSE TOOLS THAT
THEY CAN PULL OUT OF THE BOX AND
USE RIGHT IN THE CLASSROOMS SO-
WE USE ONLINE IT'S A GREAT
STRATEGY- THERE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT WE NEED OUR HANDS ON- BUT
BUT AS A WHOLE WE'RE TRYING TO
USE ALL THE DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES. SO WE REMEMBER THE
FEW MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE IS THE
I THINK WE SHOULD- MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THE FUNDING TO THE
PARTICULAR THIS HIGH SCHOOL
AGRICULTURAL TECHNICAL-
EDUCATION CLASSES BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN THIS IS WHERE WE CAN GET
SOME OF THOSE KIDS TO GET. LOST
IN THE SHUFFLE AND ONE TEACHER
IN A SMALL COMMUNITY THE ONLY A
ONE ACT TEACHER THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE TO DO IT AND THEN IT JUST
TAKES THE BASICS AND NOT SOME IS
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE NEED. OUT IN
THE FIELD SO- I THINK WE NEED TO
REALLY RELATE THIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT TECHNICAL- SO TECHNICAL
SUPPORT IN THOSE HIGH SCHOOLS.
EIGHT EXACT AND SEEING THAT THE
SHOPS ON THAT SIDE OF IT STAY
OPEN WEEK WE SEE PROGRAMS BUT
NOW THEY HAVE. AN AG TEACHER BUT
IT'S NOT THE SAME TYPES OF
THINGS THAT I WENT THROUGH WHEN
THERE WAS A ROBUST. HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS OUT THERE. MYSTERIES
AND I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION THE COMMENTS AND-
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT THE
SALINAS VALLEY- AND YOU KNOW
HAVING A FIRST HAND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE INCREDIBLE
SUCCESS THAT HARD NOW. I HAS
HAD- WITH THEIR AG PROGRAMS- A
LOT OF THAT WOULD BE POSSIBLE
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT FROM THE
INDUSTRY INDUSTRIES PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN MAKING THIS
POSSIBLE I AND SO IF YOU COULD
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TOO I THINK
YOU ALLUDED TO IT IN YOUR
COMMENTS BUT YOU SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TO THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
THAT PARTNERSHIP. AND IT REALLY
IS A MODEL FOR OTHER
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE LEVERAGING OUR JUNIOR
COLLEGE SYSTEM TO MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE TELL IT'S I'M I HAVE
GOOSE BUMPS JUST BECAUSE I'M
THINKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW I MEAN.
THEIR KIDS WHAT WHAT THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY'S DID.
INSULIN IS EXTREMELY RARE
THROUGHOUT THE NATION YOU SEE IT
AT LAND GRANT UNIVERSITIES BUT-
I HAVEN'T BAG STEERING I HAVE TO
AG STEERING MEETINGS A YEAR.
THIS IS C. LEVEL EXECUTIVES
OWNERS PEOPLE WITH NAMES ON THE
BUILDING. WE CAN LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE IT'S A LOT EASIER TO HAVE
A BIG COMPANY WRITE YOU A CHECK
THEN HAVE SOMEONE COME IN AND
SAT DOWN. AND TRULY EXPLAIN WHAT
THEIR COMPANY NEEDS. VACANCY
AROUND THE CORNERS THEY CAN SEE
THINGS THAT FOR ME I CAN WALK
THROUGH THE FACTORY A THOUSAND
TIMES AND I'M NOT GOING TO SEE
ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT THAT FRONT
THOSE PEOPLE COMING IN THAT
MAKES A WORLD OF DIFFERENCE. AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO REPLICATE IT'S
AMAZING TO SEE IT IN SALINAS AND
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT CHALLENGE
FOR THE REST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TRULY BE THAT
ENGAGED. THE THING THAT THEY
THEY ARE ABLE TO GIVE US THAT
HUGE VISIONING BELL LOT OF
PLACES THAT HAVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
ADVISORY COMMITTEES ARE THOSE
THOSE. A LOT OF TIMES AT SEA
LEVEL EXECUTIVE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
SERVO VALVE THEY'RE USING OUT IN
THE IN THE PLANT. SO WE WANT
THEM TO VISION AND THEN WE NEED
THOSE OTHER THAT THOSE FRONT
LINE MANAGERS THAT ARE REALLY
GOING TO TELL US THOSE SPECIFIC
SKILLS THAT WE WANT TO USE. AND
AGAIN I DIDN'T CREATE THAT
HARTNELL- I WAS ABLE TO COME
OVER AND BE PART OF THAT. AND SO
THERE THERE AND THEN BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT GIVES US A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE WHEN WE'RE APPLYING
FOR GRANTS. IT GIVES US ALL OF
THOSE OTHER THINGS. AND THEN YES
THEY SUPPORT US- AMAZING AMAZING
SUPPORT. NOT ONLY WITH CHECKS.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT A LOT ABOUT
INTERNSHIPS RIGHT IS. YOU TAKE
AN INTERN AND YOU PUT HIM IN A
IN A IN A JOB PLACE. THAT TAKES
THAT EXCELLENT EMPLOYEE AND MAKE
SOME ABOUT HALF AS EFFICIENT AS
THEY WERE BEFORE. BUT IF YOU DO
THAT LONG ENOUGH AND WE CAN
SCALE IT MORE AND MORE PEOPLE WE
CAN GET THEM OUT THERE AND AGAIN
THIS IS THIS IS INDUSTRY LEADERS
THAT ARE TRULY LOOKING AT THE
LONG RUN SORRY. I LOVE MY
INDUSTRY SERVICE FOR SURE.
THROUGH THE MEMBERS SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS- DEAN THANK YOU VERY
INSPIRING THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
HEAR AND HEAR EVERYTHING YOU
MENTIONED TODAY. THANK YOU SIR.
WELL I WANT TO WELCOME. THE
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR SECOND PANEL
MADE UP OF AGTECH PETITIONERS
WHO WILL GIVE US SOME INSIGHT
INTO THE WORLD AG TECHNOLOGY
CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED IN USE
IN THE FIELD. OUR FIRST
PRESENTER IS DON CAMERON VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL MANAGER OF
. TERRANOVA RANCH. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN VIA PADILLA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
GUESTS TODAY. BOB MY NAME IS DON
CAMERON AND I MANAGE TERRANOVA
RANCH WHICH- AS YOU'VE SEEN FROM
MY RESUME I'M A FARMER AND FARM
OVER TWENTY FIVE DIFFERENT
CROPS. INCLUDING ORGANIC IN
FRESNO COUNTY- IN THE CENTER OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. YOU KNOW
AGRICULTURE IS CHANGING AND
CHANGING RAPIDLY. NOT JUST
GROWING DIFFERENT CROPS. MOORE
SAYS- MORE SUSTAINABLE WAYS BUT
FARMING AND A NEW AND DIFFERENT
WAY WITH WITH TECHNOLOGY. CAN
WERE E EVER BRINGING THIS
TECHNOLOGY ON FARM AT A RAPID
PACE. WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO
BRING IN A NEW GENERATION OF
WORKERS- ONES THAT COME WITH THE
EXPERTISE IN ROBOTICS.
TECHNOLOGY INFORMATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION M. AND
UNDERSTANDING OF NEW AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS. IN FARMING WE
NEED TO MEASURE TRACK AND REPORT
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR FARM
OPERATION. NOT NOT ONLY FOR
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE BUT FOR
FINDING ETTER WAYS TO USE OUR
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES WHILE
PRODUCING FRESH HEALTHY FOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION IN THE
WORLD. WE NEED HIGHLY TRAINED
EMPLOYEES ON FARM WITH NEW
SKILLS. WELL SOME OF THE THINGS
WE ARE DOING ON FARM JUST TO
SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
MECHANIZATION. YEAH WE'RE USING
AUTOMATED IRRIGATION SYSTEMS-
WERE USING MECHANICAL PEPPER
HARVESTING- ELECTRONIC SORTERS
AND IMPLEMENTATION HONOR TO
MIDDLE HARVESTERS BUT WE'RE ALSO
WE'RE ALSO TRYING GLAZER WEEDERS
CARE FIELD TO SEE IF WE CAN
ACTUALLY CONTROL WEEDS WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY. WE'RE FOR ACTUALLY-
FOR ELIMINATING A LOT OF THE
HAND HARVEST WHEREVER POSSIBLE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH A GROUP OF
POSTDOCS STUDENTS THAT HAVE A
START UP FROM STANFORD THAT ARE
PRODUCING NITROGEN FERTILIZER
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE- USING SOLAR
POWER. SO L. WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT ALL DIFFERENT WAYS TO BRING
TECHNOLOGY ON FARM- WERE WORKING
WITH THE COMPANY RIGHT NOW TO-
AS WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD WE KNOW
THAT ELECTRIC TRACTORS OF SOME-
IN OUR IN OUR FUTURE. AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
STORING LOW PRICED ELECTRICITY.
USING THE TRACTORS AND THEN
PUSHING THE POWER BACK INTO THE
GRID WHEN PRICES ARE HIGH SO
THAT WE CAN SUPPLY POWER TO THE
GRID AND REDUCE OUR COSTS. SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY- COMING
SOME COLLECTIVELY YOU HEARD
EARLIER WE HAVEN'T EVEN
DISCOVERED YET. BUT CURRENTLY.
WHEN ONE OF OUR TRACTORS HAS A
PROBLEM WHAT WE DO IT GETS
CONNECTED TO A COMPUTER FOR
DIAGNOSIS OF THE PROBLEM. YEAH
WHEN WE VIEW AERIAL PHOTOS OF
OUR CROPS FOR MOISTURE STRESS.
YOU KNOW WHO'S GOING TO DO THE
INTERPRETATION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO PUT THAT DATA
INTO ACTION. ONE REASON WOULD DO
RECEIVE DATA FROM OUR TECHNOLOGY
PROVIDERS WHO'S GONNA BE DOING
THE ANALYSIS. YOU KNOW. ON FARM
ROBOTICS WHO'S GOING TO BE DOING
THE OPERATION THE MAINTENANCE
AND THE REPAIRS. HELP WHEN WE DO
USE LASER WEEDERS WHO'S GOING TO
PROGRAM AND MONITOR AND MAKE THE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS. SO THE WE
ONLY KILL THE WEEDS AND NOT OUR
CROPS. WE HAVE CIGNA COMPLIANCE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT. WHO'S GOING TO BE
COLLECTING THE DATA AND WHO'S
GOING TO BE INTERPRETING THAT
DATA. AND MONITORING OUR WATER
USAGE. AND AS I SAID WHO'S GONNA
BE RUNNING OUR AUTOMATED
IRRIGATION SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN
BE MORE PRECISE WITH THE WATER
THAT WE DO HAVE. THIS ISN'T
ABOUT REPLACING OUR CURRENT FARM
WORKFORCE. BECAUSE WE VITALLY
NEED THEM. BUT WE DO NEED TO
TRAIN THOSE THAT ARE WILLING. TO
ENTER INTO SOME OF THESE NEWER
HIGHER PAYING JOBS- SO THAT THEY
CAN ADVANCE WITHIN OUR WITHIN
OUR FARM. HELLO THIS IS ABOUT
GIVING LOCAL TALENT YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN MANY SONS AND
DAUGHTERS OF FOUR FOUR OF
CURRENT FARMWORKERS THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO OBTAIN THE HIGH
PAYING CAREERS IN AGRICULTURE.
THIS IS ABOUT LONG TERM CHANGE
IT'S ABOUT REPLACING THE HUDDLE
WITH LAYS WITH LASERS. REPLACING
HAND HARVEST WITH ROBOTICS IT'S
ABOUT AUTOMATING THE FARM AND
IT'S ABOUT PRECISION FARMING.
IT'S ABOUT USING TECHNOLOGIES TO
PROVIDE HEALTHIER SAFER WELL
PAYING LONG TERM CAREERS IN
AGRICULTURE. WE NEED TO MAKE
JOBS IN AGRICULTURE ATTRACTIVE.
THE ADAGE HAD BEEN IN THE PAST
YOU KNOW LONG HOURS LOW PAY.
THAT HAVE TYPIFIED AGRICULTURE-
MANY YEARS AGO THIS SCENARIOS
CHANGED. AND THE IMAGE OF
AGRICULTURE NEEDS TO CHANGE AS
WELL. YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN SAID
BEFORE BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
ACCURATE AGRICULTURE ATTRACTIVE
OR AT LEAST EXCITING CHALLENGING
AND REWARDING. WE NEED TO
ATTRACT YOUNG LOCAL TALENT FOR
OUR FARMS FOR CAREERS. THIS IS
REALLY A TREMENDOUS NEED FOR
LOCAL THERE'S JUST A TREMENDOUS
NEED FOR LOCAL STUDENTS FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES TO FILL THESE NEEDS
IN THE SILICON VALLEY AND REALLY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE PH DIS OR PEOPLE
WITH FOUR YEAR DEGREES. FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S REYES BEEN RAISED
ON A FARM. WE NEED TALENT THAT'S
CAPABLE OF LEARNING AND ADAPTING
CRUNCHING NUMBERS WORKING
OPERATING. MAINTAINING NEW
TECHNOLOGY ON FARM. WE FOUND
THAT HIRING LOCAL HELP THE
COMMUNITY IT HELPS THE STUDENTS
AND IT HELPS THEIR FAMILY
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES WHILE
PROVIDING ROLE MODELS FOR OTHERS
IN THE COMMUNITY TO SUCCEED. WE
WANT TO KEEP THE STUDENTS HERE
TO REMAIN IN THE REGION WHERE
THEY GREW UP. WHILE THE BALK
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP FOR OTHERS
. IN ADDITION. STUDENT
DEVELOPMENT WE DESPERATELY IN
ADDITION TO THE STATE
DEVELOPMENT WE DESPERATELY NEED
RURAL BROADBAND- TO CONNECT OUR
FARM. YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN BILLS PASSED WE
HAVE MONEY THAT IS BEING PUT
FORWARD TO THE BROADBAND ISSUE
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. BUT YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES YOU KNOW. IT IT'S
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT WHEN WE'RE
USING INTERNET SPEEDS OF SEVEN
MEGABITS PER SECOND OR LESS. TO
TRY AND DOWNLOAD TECHNOLOGY
PHOTOS OF OUR OF OUR CROP STRESS
. AND EVEN MORE SO. THE IT'S
EVEN MORE TRYING AND MORE
DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS TRYING TO
RECEIVE THEIR EDUCATION IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. NO WE WE'VE HAD SOME
BY SOME OF OUR WORKERS HAVE HAD
TO USE A CELL PHONE. TO TETHER
THREE TABLETS TO THEIR CELL
PHONE TO GET THEIR KIDS
EDUCATION AND I GUARANTEE OF
THAT DOESN'T WORK. HELP MY LAST
MY LAST PRICE PRICE QUOTE FOR
BRINGING. TRUE BROADBAND ON FARM
. TWENTY TWENTY MEGABITS UP
TWENTY DOWN WHICH IS HARDLY HIGH
SPEED INTERNET. ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND AS YOU CAN
TELL WE DIDN'T GO THAT WAY. YEAH
I WAS UP THERE OUTRAGEOUS. WE
NEED COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO BE
PART OF OUR SOLUTION. WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THEM TO
DO IT TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP THE
STAFF PROVIDE THE PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDE THE HANDS ON TRAINING TO
TEACH THE SKILLS OF THE FUTURE.
WE NEED THE INSTRUCTORS TO
COMMUNICATE AND PARTNER WITH
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS. AND LOCAL
FARMS FOR PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS. SO THAT THEIR
CURRICULUM REFLECTS THE LATEST
INFORMATION AND THE NEEDS OF THE
AG INDUSTRY. A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO. WE HIRED A STUDENT FROM
WEST HILLS COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WHO LIVES IN A VERY
DISADVANTAGED RURAL COMMUNITY OF
. AND HIS PARENTS ARE
FARMWORKERS WE HAVE AN INTERN
PROGRAM PROGRAM ON OUR FARMING
OPERATION. SHE'S CONTINUING HER
EDUCATION. WELL WHILE WORKING
WITH THE EXPECTATION OF BECOMING
A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE AND MAKING
FINANCIALLY REWARDING CAREERS IN
AGRICULTURE. I PERSONALLY SEEING
THE CHANGES THAT HER ATTITUDE
FOR PERSONAL GROWTH HER PRIDE OF
WORK AND MORE IMPORTANTLY HER
SELF CONFIDENCE AND SELF ESTEEM
SINCE JOINING OUR TEAM. EGGER
CULTURE NEEDS DEDICATED PROGRAMS
IN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS. ESPECIALLY
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES- THAT
PIQUES THE INTEREST OF STUDENTS
AND WANT THEM TO MAKE A CAREER
IN AGRICULTURE. WITH OVER THREE
HUNDRED DIFFERENT JOBS IN
AGRICULTURE AVAILABLE OUR ROLE
COMMUNITIES AND FARMS NEED YOUR
SUPPORT. WE NEED THE BEST
EDUCATION THAT MONEY CAN BUY FOR
A ROLE CULTURAL KIRK'S PERFECT
CULTURALLY DIVERSE. ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS SO PLEASE
DON'T LEAVE THEM IN A BEHIND.
YOU KNOW WHY NOT PROVIDE
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES TO STUDENTS
WHO PURSUE A CAREER IN
AGRICULTURE. AS MANY TIMES THEY
MUST WORK TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FAMILIES ECONOMIC NEEDS. EGGER
CULTURE NEEDS YOUR HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED YOUR HELP. WE
NEED HELP IN ADDING TO THE
WORKFORCE WITH HIGHLY TECHNICAL
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE SKILLS
FOR JOBS THAT HAVEN'T YET BEEN
CREATED. SO I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT BEFORE YOU TODAY AND-
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR SOME
QUESTIONS ABSOLUTELY. SECRETARY
WELL YOU SHOULD HAVE HAD TO COME
SPEAK ON THE FLOOR ABOUT
BROADBAND INTERNET HOLLYWOOD
FORTY YEARS AGO BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN PREACHING TO THE CHOIR IN
THIS BUILDING FOR YEARS WE
FINALLY GOT THE BILL THROUGH BUT
LIKE ANYTHING IT TAKES TIME TO
IMPLEMENT BUT WE'RE WE'RE DOING
IT SO. BUT YOU KNOW- I WAS
TALKED EARLIER ABOUT ONE OF THE
CLIENTS I WENT OUT TO
CONSTITUENTS YESTERDAY CUSTOM
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
GET IN INTERNET FROM TO HIS
BUSINESS AND BREAKS MY HEART
THAT HE HAD TO GO DO THAT AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO. DO
SOME KIND OF INCENTIVES FOR SOME
OF THE- OTHER POINT THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP THAT I THINK THAT WE
pAGING WORKFORCE. THEIR WORK
FORCES OUT IN THE FIELDS RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE NOT AS MANY BUT THE
WORK FORCE'S OLDER. AND THEN WE
DO NEED TO BACK FILL WITH SOME.
TECHNOLOGY AND STUDENTS AND-
PEOPLE THAT UNDERSTAND THAT
AGRICULTURE IS A REALLY GOOD
VIBRANT JOB. AND FOR ME I'VE
OWNED A FARM WITH MY BROTHERS
AND THERE'S NOTHING BETTER THAN
THE FRESH AIR. TO BE OUTSIDE THE
TOUCH THE DIRTAND PLANT
SOMETHING AND WATCH IT GROW I
MEAN I HAVE THIS WHOLE DIFFERENT
FEELING THAT MAYBE SOME PEOPLE
DO. ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
LOOKING AT HIM I. WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE. YOUR COMMENTS AND I THINK
THE NEXT THREE. IS THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF FAMILY FARMS THAT ARE
PRETTY LARGE. AND THEIR SISTER
THEY WERE HOPING TO PASS IT DOWN
TO THE FAMILY. AND THEIR
CHILDREN. QUITE APART NECESSARY
INTERESTED. AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO LOSE IT SO YOU KNOW AS WE GET
OLDER WE WANT TO HOLD ON TO OUR
LAND- LOOKING AT MAYBE- DOING.
SMALLER FARMS PLUS. AND MAYBE
GIVING THE A FARMER OF THE MAIN
PROPERTY- OWNER A TAX CREDIT. TO
MAYBE DO A LEASE FOR MAYBE
THIRTY OR FORTY ACRES ON THEIR
PROPERTY. I'M TRYING TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO LOSE MY FARMS. AND I
DON'T WANT TO ALL TO BE SOLD TO
CORPORATIONS BUT I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP THAT YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT. YOU KNOW WEEK
WE PROBABLY SEE MORE FARMS FOR
SALE. LARGE LARGER FAMILY FARMS
FOR SALE THAT I'VE EVER SEEN IN
MY LIFETIME. THERE IS A THERE'S
A JEFF DEFINITE GENERATIONAL
CHANGE HAPPENING. THAT COUPLED
WITH- I THINK A LOT OF THE
FARMERS HAVE JUST- HAD ENOUGH OF
THE REGULATIONS- IT'S TOUGH
FARMING IN CALIFORNIA MORE SO
THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN THE
UNION. I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
CREATIVE. WE WANT TO KEEP THE
LAND AND PRODUCTION AS WELL AS
WE CAN AS YOU KNOW THE WATER
ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
TREMENDOUS. ASHLEY DOWN AND IN
OUR REGION- WERE WERE IN A
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASIN.
SO I WOULD THINK ANY OPPORTUNITY
TO KEEP THE FARM. IN PRODUCTION.
IF IT IF IT MEANS SPLITTING IT
UP LEASING GROUND- TO OTHER
FARMERS GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FARM I THINK
FANTASTIC. WE GET IT IS A
DIFFICULT CHALLENGE IT'S HUGE
CHALLENGE ROOM BECAUSE THE PRICE
OF EQUIPMENT COMPUTERS THE NEW
WATER YOUR ATTENTION SYSTEMS BUT
I LOOK AT- A GROUP THAT'S HERE
NOR THE CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR
BLAND BUT BIT PLAN BASED
LEARNING AND THEY'RE TEACHING
PEOPLE TO BE FARMERS EXACTLY AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE FAR IN BUT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE LAND THEY CAN'T
GET THE FINANCING IN THE YOU
KNOW. SO I'M JUST TRYING TO
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX IS HOW CAN
WE KEEP THE LAND THE LAND THAT I
LOVE IN MANY LOVE. AND KEEP IT
VIABLE THING MAKE SURE X. THREE
MEANS OF PRODUCTION SO YOU KNOW
WHAT I IF YOU HAVE ANYWHERE IN
THE NATION THIS DOING SOMETHING
CREATIVE OR I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
THAT BUT- ONE OF MY GOOD FRIENDS
RICHARD ROMINGER WHO RECENTLY
PASSED AWAY WAS A VERY I ADAM
AND WORKED WITH ME IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE COULD DO THAT.
AND SO- I WOULD APPRECIATE ANY
KIND OF INPUT THE MOVE YOU OR
OTHERS MIGHT BE ABLE TO GIVE US
NO I AGREE THAT RICHARD WAS A
FRIEND OF MINE AS WELL YEAH.
VERY WONDERFUL PERSON AND I AM
NOT UNBELIEVABLE AMOUNT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE AND WISDOM.
YEAH BUT- I SEE THERE ARE YOU
KNOW TO GET INTO FARMING DON'T
AS YOU SAID YOU. HAVE TO THE
LAND. YOU CAN LEASE LAND. AND
THERE'S IN SECURITY WITH THAT.
BUT IF YOU HAVE THE RIGHT MATCH
UP. I THINK I THINK IT'S A
VIABLE OPTION IT'S A GOOD WAY TO
GET PEOPLE INVOLVED IN IT IN IN
FARMING- IACTUALLY HAD NO FORM
BACKGROUND- BEFORE I GOT
INVOLVED IN AGRICULTURE. AT IT
AS YOU SAY THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT BEING OUT THERE PLANTING
SEEDS WATCHING THINGS GROW
PRODUCING CROPS THAT REALLY THAT
FEED THE WORLD AND- IT'S VERY
SATISFYING. AND I WOULDN'T TRADE
IT FOR ANYTHING YEAH THAT BUT
YOU KNOW THAT'S HARD TO EXPLAIN
TO SOME. LET'S FACE IT TO A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT. OR TO SOMEONE-
EARLY IN THEIR COLLEGE CAREER-
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF. OF BRINGING
PEOPLE INTO AGRICULTURE. I SEE.
AND I THINK THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
THE COMMONALITY I THINK THAT
THOSE WHO LIVE IN A FARM
ENVIRONMENT. TEND TO TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED THEY DON'T LOOK AT IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY AS A CAREER PATH-
I THINK THAT IF THEY LOOK BEYOND
THAT. AND SOMEHOW WE NEED TO
MAKE THE CHANGE WE NEED TO SHOW
THEM THAT- THAT IT CAN BE
EXCITING AND IT CAN BE REALLY
REALLY REWARDING AND A GREAT
PLACE TO WORK IN A LOT OF. IT IS
A CHALLENGE I WOULD REMEMBER
NINE CHANGE NO DOUBT ABOUT IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. YEAH RICH WAS VERY
DIFFERENT WHEN TO. DISTRIBUTE
THANK YOU I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON- YOU KNOW I
SHARED EARLIER THAT I'VE VISITED
ABOUT ELEVEN FIVE OF ELEVEN I'VE
BEEN ON ELEVEN TEARS- TO TWO
DIFFERENT FARMS AND- YOU KNOW I
HEAR THE SAME THINGS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN HOW ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS BUT- YET WHEN I
SPEAK TO YOU AND TO. THOSE OF
YOU IN THE INDUSTRY YOUR EYES
LIGHT UP WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU DO AND SO I THINK PART
OF THE MESSAGE IS NOT GETTING
ACROSS TO THE YOUNGER
GENERATIONS. ABOUT HOW REWARDING
IT IS AND SOLD AT YOU KNOW I
DON'T CLAIM TO HAVE A SOLUTION
TO THAT OBVIOUSLY BUT- I THINK
YOU KNOW WILL THE- ADVANTAGES OF
WHAT YOU DO SHOULD BE
HIGHLIGHTED- MORE OFTEN AND- NOT
JUST ADVANTAGES ABOUT ABOUT HOW
YOU MIGHT HOW MUCH YOU ENJOY IN
THAT WE DO FEED. YOU KNOW THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY THAT'S
REALLY SOMETHING IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL IF YOU KNOW A WHOLE
BUNCH WAS GIVEN TO. POLITICS
MAINLY TO HELP SOMEBODY RIGHT
AND BUT YOU DO THIS AND YOU HELP
OF THE DEVIL CALIFORNIA AND THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY SO MAYBE
SOME MARKETING WILL WOULD HELP.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY I'M FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MAYBE YOU
KNOW PREACHING TO THE CHOIR
YOU'VE ALREADY DONE IT BUT I SEE
IT A LOT WHEN I WAS A TEACHER.
WE WOULD DO WITH THE YOU KNOW
BRING THE COW- TO THE TO OUR
CLASSROOM AND THAT YOU KNOW THE
KIDS GOT TO EXPERIENCE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT YOU KNOW MILKING THE
COW I GET THE OUR FRESH FOOD OF
THE MONTH. KIND OF PROGRAM THAT
WAS AVAILABLE TO ME DOWN AND
SEVEN CALIFORNIA AND THAT WAS
THE EXTENT OF KIND OF FARMING
AND TALKING ABOUT GOD YOU KNOW
PRODUCE AND WHERE IT COMES FROM.
AND THAT'S SO TINY I MEAN THE
KIDS WERE JUST MORE INTERESTED
IN THE YOU KNOW IN THE TASTING
THE FOOD NOT NECESSARILY AND
WHERE IT CAME FROM- AND THEY
THEY WE EXPLAIN THAT RIGHT BUT-
IT WAS TOO ASSEMBLY WOMAN- I
GEHRY CURRY'S POINT. THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH- POSITIVE ADVERTISING OR
POSITIVE- COMMUNICATION WITH
STUDENTS THAT MAY BE IN YOU KNOW
ARE. INTERESTED AND DOING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I KNOW.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT OF THEM THE
- YOU KNOW OF THIS MAY. BY
WANTED TO SHARE THAT BECAUSE MY
PURSE. AS A- AS A TEACHER IS THE
IT'S JUST SOMETHING TO SOMEBODY
DOES AS OPPOSED TO SOME BUT
SOMETHING THAT. WE CAN DEAL WITH
CELL. WANT TO SHARE THAT. NO I
AGREE COMPLETELY WITH YOU WE ARE
VERY TRANSPARENT IN OUR FARMING
OPERATION- WE HOST. A LOT OF
GROUPS A LOT OF STUDENTS. FROM
UC DAVIS FROM FRESNO STATE. FROM
WEST HILLS COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
REBATE WE POSTED- OVER MANY
YEARS GROUPS FROM- CHIPPING GO
UNIVERSITY IN MEXICO- THEY COME
UP THEY THEY ALWAYS STOP AT OUR
LOCATION WE GIVE THEM WE USUALLY
SPEND A FULL DAY WITH THEIR
GROUP THEY MAY HAVE TWO BUSES-
WE HOST THE AG LEADERSHIP GROUP-
THE NEW FELT SCHOLARS OUT ABOUT
PRIMARILY IN AUSTRALIA THEY'RE
NOW EXPANDING THROUGHOUT THE NOT
ONLY THE US BUT THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD. THAT WE HOST THEM EVERY
YEAR- AND WHAT WE MAKE OURSELVES
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS ANY
STUDENT THAT WANTS TO BE
INVOLVED WE BRING THEM ON FARM
AND WE DO HAVE A PROGRAM. OF
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM TO WHERE WE
WILL. SPEND THE TIME AND WILL
EDUCATE THEM. AND YOU DON'T WE
FOUND THAT THE VALUE IN THAT HAS
BEEN IMMENSE YOU KNOW THE TWO
PEOPLE WE'VE HAD SO FAR. I THINK
REMAIN WITH US FOR A LONG TIME.
THE HELP. THANK YOU- I JUST LIKE
TO ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT I MEAN.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO NEW
FARMERS. WE HEAR I HEAR A LOT OF
FUNDING FOR FROM THE FEDS FOR
VETERANS. BUT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW HOW CAN WE GET
THAT INFORMATION TO NEW FARMERS
AND THE QUESTION THE REALLY HOT
THAT I WANTED ASKING IS PROBABLY
ADDRESS TO YOUR CLIENT. ARE
THERE ARE THERE OPPORTUNITIES IS
TO TEACH TRAIN AND USE AG. TECH
IN URBAN SETTINGS. SOME OF IT I
THINK YOU CAN I MEAN I I'M
ALWAYS SUPPORTIVE OF URBAN
FARMS- SMALL FARMS REALLY ALL OF
AGRICULTURE- BECAUSE I THINK
ONCE YOU GET STARTED I THINK YOU
GET HOOKED. AND YOU MAY START IN
A SMALL URBAN SETTING. AND YOU
MAY LIKE IT SO MUCH THAT YOU MAY
EXPAND TO THE ALPS OUTSKIRTS OF
THE OF THE COMMUNITY. CAN START
SOMETHING A LITTLE LARGER. AND I
THINK THERE'S ANOTHER A REAL
EVOLUTION THAT TAKES PLACE. HOW
YOU GET I MEAN I GUESS HOW DO
YOU BRING THE PEOPLE TO. THERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE- YOU KNOW I
THINK PART OF IT'S THEIR
INTERESTS AND THE GOVERNMENT TO
TRY SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND- YOU
KNOW THE ACTUAL HANDS ON BOOTS
ON THE GROUND. YOU REALLY NEED
THE EXPERIENCE YOU NEED TO YOU
NEED TO. WE NEED TO WANT TO DO
IT I GUESS SANTA. AND I THINK
THERE ARE LOCATIONS YOU KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT THE- CENTER DAVIS
THAT- HAS TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR-
FOR BOTH STUDENTS TO WANT TO GET
INVOLVEDIN AGRICULTURE THEY CAN
BE TRAINED THEIR THEIR PROGRAM
HE ALSO IS IN THE- SILICON
VALLEY THEY HAVE- THE CAN
WORKING AND IN. OUR REGION AS
WELL SO. WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
POSSIBLE WAYS TO GET IN- BUT AS
I SAY YOU DON'T HAVE TO OWN THE
LAND YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE NEW
EQUIPMENT- THERE THERE'S WAYS
YOU CAN DO IT WE OFFER THAT THAT
THAT'S- PRETTY MUCH I GOT
STARTED HERE. BOB WELL I WAS WE
HAVE A TEACHER WHO. I'M NOT
ALWAYS HERE I'M ALWAYS LISTENING
TO HER- BECAUSE SHE HER HER
ASPECTS OF AS A TEACHER- BUT STE
I DON'T KNOW IF THE STATE
SOMETIMES ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH.
RIGHT WHEN IT COMES TO EARLY. I
MEAN WHAT YOU'RE WHAT WE'RE
ALWAYS TAUGHT THAT THIRD GRADE
FOURTH GRADE IS WHEN. PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY MAKING THE DECISION WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO. I WE ONLY HAVE
AG FAST ONCE A YEAR THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH. YEAH WE SHOULD BE DOING
MORE WE SHOULD JUST IT SHOULDN'T
BE A- A FIELD TRIP ONCE A YEAR
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT IT'S
IN OUR CURRICULUM. IN OUR
SCHOOLS. IS THAT THEY ARE TAUGHT
EARLY ON. RIGHT WE ANOTHER FOUR
H. PROGRAMS RIGHT ARE ALWAYS IN
NEED OF FUNDING RIGHT AT THE AT
THE- SOME OF THE LOWER LEVELS-
FFA THE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES.
BUT BUT THERE HAS TO BE FUNDING
FOR THEM AND- MADE IT SOUND LIKE
A BROKEN RECORD I'M SURE YOU
HEAR ALL THE TIME. THE THING OF
THE FIGHT FOR THE MONEY I MEAN.
IT'S A GREAT TIME RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THERE IS. A BUDGET
SURPLUS AND WE KNOW GOING INTO
THIS NEXT YEAR THERE'S GOING TO
BE ADDITIONAL- SURPLUS AVAILABLE
. AND MAYBE THIS IS A GREAT TIME
TO INVEST. SOME OF THAT MONEY.
INTO PROGRAMS THAT WILL EXPOSE.
YOUNG CHILDREN. AND JUNIOR HIGH
AND HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL OF
STUDENTS. TO AGRICULTURE MAYBE
IN A LITTLE DIFFERENT WAY. THAN
IT'S BEEN BEFORE. WITH A SPIN ON
TECHNOLOGY. BECAUSE I GUARANTEE
OF THE THEY KNOW THEY KNOW
TECHNOLOGY THE COMPLETE COMPUTER
GAMES LIKE THE GOING OUT OF
STYLE YEAH- AND HOW DO WE GET
THAT EXPERTISE INTO AGRICULTURE
. YEAH BECAUSE I THINK IF
THEY'RE GOOD AT THAT BIG THEY
CAN HANDLE. A LOT OF THE MORE
THE MORE MALPRACTICE TO THE
COULD PROBABLY PICK OUR
TECHNOLOGY UP VERY RAPIDLY. I
AGREE WITH YOU- I JUST HAVE ONE
COMMENT YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD FOR ME WE HAVE NOT FUNDED
FOR H. FOR YEARS LIKE THAT
MINIMALLY AND WE LOST OUR
EXTENSION PEOPLE THAT WERE OUT
THERE COORDINATING ALL OF THAT
FOR EIGHT YEARS AND FUNDING
NEEDS TO GO BACK TO THAT PROGRAM
WHETHER IN A RURAL AREA BUT IT
URBAN AREA THESE KIDS COULD
LEARN FROM THE TECHNOLOGY TWO
FOUR H. ONLINE. YOU KNOW WITH IT
WITH THE PROPER INSTRUCTIONS BUT
WE DID NOT FIND THEM AND IT HAS
BROKE MY HEART I THAT I CAME UP
THROUGH FOR AGE IN MY VERY FIRST
WORD EVERYONE WAS A FOR EACH
AWARD I RAISED ANIMALS GRAND
CHAMPION LAMB I DID ALL THAT
STUFF THOSE KIDS DON'T GET
ANYMORE. SO OKAY- OFFENBACH'S. I
AGREE WITH YOU AND REALLY
PLEASED. WE SAW THE UC. SYSTEM
CUT DRESS. WE'RE NOW FOR GOING
BACK IN. FORCING FARMING VISORS
BEING HIRED WE'RE SEEING. THE
OUTREACH TO NOT ONLY. TO THE
MADE CROPS IN THE STATE BUT TO
THE SMALL FARMERS. THE SOCIALLY
DIVERSE FARMERS AND ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGED. SO WE'RE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY MOVING FORWARD. WE
DEFINITELY DID. THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MEASURE. NEXT UNFORTUNATELY
PREVENT. NHTSA WILL NOT HERE
TODAY WITH THIS BUT IN HIS PLACE
WE WANT TO WELCOME CARLO MONDAVI
. CO FOUNDER AND CHIEF FOR CHIEF
FOR MAIN OFFICE AND JAKE WINTERS
CHIEF OF STAFF. AT MONARCH
TRACTOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. WITH
A STEP INTO THIS. AWESOME AS
pWINTERS ON CHIEF OF STAFF AT
MODERN TRACTOR BESIDE ME AS
PARLIAMENT AVI ARE CO FOUNDER
AND CHIEF FARMINGOFFICER-
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
TAKING THE TIME TODAY I TO SET
UP THIS MEETING AND
FACILITATING- IT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT AND A VERY PERTINENT
TO THE- EVENTS. FIVE JUMPING
RIGHT IN OUR HAVE A SLIGHT. THE
WE'RE GONNA BE IS A FREE. HERE I
FEEL FREE FALL LAW- AS WE MOVE
THROUGH- MARK TRACTOR OR- TEAM
OF A HUNDRED STE HI. OR SO
PEOPLE DOWN IN. CAL I HAVE A NEW
. TO MAKE FARMING SUSTAINABLE
PROFITABLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
AND WE PLAN TO DO THAT BY
ENABLING ECONOMIC GROWTH THROUGH
THE DEPLOYMENT OF SMART AND
CLEAN. TECHNOLOGIES ARE
PRINCIPALLY ARE ZERO EMISSION
TRACTOR. WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED-
THREE OF MANY CHALLENGES THAT
FARMERS ARE FACING TODAY-
PRINCIPALLY- LABOR SHORTAGES
WHICH WE'VE DISCUSSED. HERE WITH
SOME OF THE OTHER PANELISTS-
BOTH FROM A ABSOLUTE SENSE IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF WORKERS
AS WELL AS THE SKILL SETS. THAT
ARE NEEDED NOW AND MOVING INTO
THE FUTURE OF AGRICULTURE. WE'RE
ALSO SEEING INCREASED SCRUTINY
ON OUR FOOD ECOSYSTEM OUR-
PEOPLE WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEIR FOOD COMES FROM- WHAT KIND
OF CHEMICALS AND PROCESSES ARE.
DONE TO ACTUALLY PRODUCE THAT
FOOD AND WHAT THE EMISSIONS
IMPACT OF THAT FOOD PRODUCTION
AREAS ARE ESPECIALLY. AS WE
START TO. RESTAURANTS AROUND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO ABOUT IT. AND FOR SOME
CONTACTS THERE- YEAH I'M A
FORMER FIRST AND I NEVER
IMAGINED MYSELF INVOLVED IN A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY BUT I'M
INCREDIBLY EXCITED- MY FIRST
GOAL WAS TO FIND A WAY THAT WE
COULD BRIDGE AWAY FROM DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS ON FARMS. I HOW CAN
GET AWAY FROM HERBICIDES AND
UNIQUE IT'S A NOISE TO PROTECT
OUR FARM BIOLOGY ARE SOIL
MICROBIOMES PROTECT ACT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE BEES FROM COLONY
COLLAPSE DISORDER IN. THE
MONARCH BUTTERFLIES ARE
DISAPPEARING AND- THEN IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN MY FAMILY LOST HALF OF
OUR CROP DUE TO DROUGHT AT MY
FAMILY'S IN THE WINE BUSINESS I. 201730% DUE TO WILDFIRE.
TWENTY TWENTY A 100% OF OUR CROP
DUE TO SMOKE TAINT. AND QUICKLY
REALIZED THAT. IF WE DON'T
PROTECT OUR CLIMATE AND THE
PLANET. THAT WHO CARES ABOUT THE
FATE SO I COMBINED WILL HAVE A
FORM THE FORM ON. IT I QUICKLY
REALIZED WE NEEDED TO WORK ON
THAT- MARC IS AN ALL ELECTRIC
DRIVER OPTIONAL SMART TRACTOR.
BY TEEN DRIVER OPTIONAL WERE
ABLE TO BRIDGE A LOT OF THE
DIVIDES THAT SEPARATE CLEAN
FARMING- FROM FROM CONVENTIONAL
FARMING- BY BEING ELECTRIC WERE
ABLE TO BRIDGE THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT ASSOCIATED- AND THEN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT THE LABOR
POOL- MY BIGGEST GOAL IS TO
PROTECT OUR OUR FARM TEAMS. SO
RIGHT NOW. I GREW UP MY FIRST
JOB AND FARMING. WAS AYE AYE
MECHANIC'S ASSISTANT. AND HE
WOULD ALWAYS TELL ME THE MOST
DANGEROUS PLACE ON THIS FARMS
THE TRACTOR SEAT. AT NOT JUST
FROM POTENTIALLY IT ROLLING
OVER. UT ALSO YOU HAVE T PUT
ON A HAZMAT SUIT EVEN TO SPRAY
ORGANIC CONTEXT REYES NOT TO
MENTION THE VERY DANGEROUS
CONVENTIONAL SPRAYS THAT CAN BE.
QUITE THE WORST TO BREED. AND
SO- BY BEING A THOMAS WERE ABLE
TO PROTECT OUR FARMERS AND THAT
WAY. PROTECTED FROM THE DANGERS
POSITION IN THE SEAT- AND THEN
ALSO- DEAL A BIT WITH THE LABOR
SHORTAGE WHICH IS- NOT.
BENEFICIAL YEAH OUR SERVICE
CARLOS TO OUR FARMERS ARE
LOOKING FOR AUTOMATION ACTUAL
INSIGHTS BASED ON REAL DATA
COLLECTED ON FIELD ARE AND HOW
MUCH VACATION. AND SO ARE WE
BUILT ON OUR TRACTOR PLATFORM I
ASK OUR LOADED IT'S A FULLY
ELECTRIC COMPACT TRACTOR- FORTY
HORSEPOWER ARE MOSTLY SEEN. IN
THE VENDOR MARKETS BUT WE DO R.
I SEE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS. PRODUCED
AND WE ARE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES. ARE HERE WE'VE BUILT
FROM THE GROUND UP USING
EXISTING COMPONENTS AND-
LEVERAGING THE AUTOMOTIVE AND
AGRICULTURAL SUPPLY CHAINS ARE.
ALSO ADDING MANY OF THE COOL
SENSORS THAT ENABLE THE DRIVER
OPTIONAL. TECHNOLOGY AND SO WE
HAVE ALL OF THE SAME INPUTS THAT
YOU SEE ON AN EXISTING DIESEL
TRACTOR. OUR FARMERS CAN GET ON
AND AN OPERATOR AFTER JUST IKE
THEY WITH THEIR TRADITIONAL ONE.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABLE TO EXECUTE
SOME OF THESE ROUTES ARE
AUTONOMOUSLY AND DO SOME WORK. I
WITHOUT AN OPERATOR ON BOARD. I
AM BECAUSE OF THIS. TO LOOK AT
SOME PRETTY SO. IMPACTS ARE TO
THE FARM ARE NOT. ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND. A YEAR AND A- SAVINGS
AND- THREE. OF CO TWO A- ARE
BEING RE. ON A TRACTOR PER YEAR
. BASIS AND SO- THIS. QUICKLY
START TO ADD UP TO SOME SERIOUS
NUMBERS- AND QUICKLY WERE BACKED
BY SOME OF THE BIGGEST NAMES IN
AGRICULTURE- MR CASE NEW HOLLAND
INDUSTRIAL IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL. PRODUCERS OF
MACHINERY AND THE OF WORLD ARE
THEY HAVE INVESTED IN MODERN
TRACTOR AS WELL AS MUSASHI WHO
IS A TIER ONE AUTOMOTIVE
SUPPLIER. TRIMBLE WHO DOES A
VARIETY OF AG TAX SOFTWARE AND
HARDWARE- HAS A- A RARE
SATELLITES TO BE USED FOR RTK
CORRECTIONS. AND VEACH V. S. T.
R. WHO DIES ARE- ONE OF THE MAIN
MANUFACTURERS OF TRACTORS OUT OF
INDIA. RECENTLY WE ALSO
ANNOUNCED THAT CNH HAS LICENSED
THE MONARCH TRACTOR TECHNOLOGY
AND WILL BE APPLYING IT TO THEIR
PRODUCT LINES. IN THE COMING
YEAR SO WE REALLY ARE SEEING
THIS TECHNOLOGY START TO I COME
INTO ITS OWN AND- AND START
PERSONALLY YEAH THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW.
OVER A QUARTER OF OUR PLANET'S
CARBON FOOTPRINTS COMING FROM
AGRICULTURE SO HAVING- THE
SECOND LARGEST TRACTOR COMPANY
IN THE WORLD LICENSE OUR
TECHNOLOGY WILL HELP US MEET OUR
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS. NOT JUST
WITH AND MARK AS A COMPANY BUT-
AS A PLANET AS WE- FIGHT TO.
DEAL WITH WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH YEAH. SO WHAT WE SEE IS
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT A BARRIER TO
ADOPTING THIS FORMAL EDUCATION.
OUR FARMERS THAT WE TALK TO THEY
SAY THAT THEY NEED REGULATIONS
ALIGNS WITH THE CURRENT STATE OF
TECHNOLOGY WHICH WILL GONNA DIVE
INTO A LITTLE BIT FURTHER HERE.
ARE THEY ALSO NEED INCENTIVES TO
SWAP OUT THEIR EXISTING DIESEL
EQUIPMENT. FOR NEW ZERO EMISSION
ONE SIDE CAPITAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR A ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE ARE
HIGHER ON THE OFFSET- BUT WE DO
MAKE THAT MONEY BACK TO- BUT
FARMING IT'S ARE. A LOW MARGIN
BUSINESS AND SO IT'S DIFFERENT
SOMETIMES REFORMS TO ACTUALLY
MAKE THE TRANSITION. UP
INCENTIVES AND WE'VE HAD GOOD
SUPPORT FROM OUR OUR CARBON AND
THE CC ARE THERE STARTED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO RUN OUR ZERO
EMISSION EQUIPMENT IN. THE
CURRENT PLAN WORKS AND WHAT THE
FRAMEWORKS OF THE FUTURE LOOK
LIKE TO INCENTIVIZE THE
TRANSITION- AND ADDITIONALLY
FARMERS ARE ASKING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CHARGING
SUPPORT- SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY. DEPLOY THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AT SCALE YEAH AND
YOU KNOW THERE'S A RECENT
MCKINSEY- STUDY THAT SHE- DECK
BY ELECTRIFY. FARMING IT'S THE
SINGLE GREATEST THING THE WE CAN
DO. TO HELP- DEAL WITH THAT
CARBON FIBER ON THE ON THE
IMPLEMENTS. ON THE ON THE- SIDE
SEES ME- ANOTHER THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LAW. DECADE I FOR BEEN FORMER
FOR A HUNDRED. ELASTICATED A
DECADE THAT WE'VE HAD. SOME
SEVERE. GIVEN EVERYTHING TO TAP
. IT'S A- AT HAD ENOUGH SUBS YOU
KNOW THESE ARE LEGACY.
INVESTMENTS THAT WE AS A FARMING
COMMUNITY AND TO OUR TRACTOR
EQUIPMENT AND ALL OF OUR
EQUIPMENT- THEY'RE MEANT TO LAST
A LONG TIME. AND SO GETTING THE
SUPPORT FROM. THE GOVERNMENT TO
BE ABLE TO SUBSIDIZE THE TO BE
ABLE TO MIGRATE AWAY. FROM THE
FOSSIL FUEL KIND OF. TRACTORS
AND EQUIPMENT AND TO- CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY I THINK WILL BE
MASSIVELY SUPPORT OF- AND
HELPFUL FOR US TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. ABSOLUTELY FIVE. ON THE
REGULATORY SIDE ARE WE WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY HIGHLIGHT TITLE
EIGHT SECTION THREE FOUR FOUR
ONE B. WE SEE THIS AS THE
PRIMARY REGULATORY ROADBLOCKS. I
TO THE LARGER ADOPTION OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA. R.
THREE FOUR ONE ONE B. IS
AMBIGUOUS TO AUTONOMOUS SYSTEMS
ARE IT IT DOESN'T ACCOUNT FOR
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES THAT HAVE HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS. OUR AND WE
BELIEVE THAT CHANGE IS NEEDED TO
THIS REGULATION AND IT'S. TIME
SENSITIVE AS WELL. I THREE FOUR
ONE FOUR. ONE B. R. THE STATE'S
THAT ALL SELF. EQUIPMENT SHALL
WIN UNDER ITS OWN POWER IN IN
MOTION. HAVE AN OPERATOR
STATIONED AT THE BEHEST OF OUR
CONTROLS. ARE AND THIS CREATES A
LOT OF AMBIGUITY IT'S UNCLEAR IF
VEHICLES THAT ARE CONTROLLED.
THROUGH AUTONOMOUS SYSTEMS OR
ARE CONTROLLED BY REMOTE
OPERATOR. I NEED A STANDARD OR
IF THE STANDARD IT HERE EVEN
APPLIES TO. ARE THESE VEHICLES
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE FIELD
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF HUMAN BEINGS
IN THE VICINITY. AND IS THIS
DOES DIRECTLY AFFECT OUR OR SO
MY LEVINE FOURMILE BY BEING ABLE
TO HAVE A TANAMI WERE ABLE TO DO
THE EXTRA PASSES TO GET INTO THE
CLEAN AROUND THE FARMING WITHOUT
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT MIGHT BE
ELECTRIC. ANOTHER BIG THING IS
ALSO- BY BEING ABLE TO HAVE AN
OPERATOR ELEVATED INTO A MANAGER
POSITION THAT IS AWAY FROM THE
TRACTOR ACTUALLY PROTECTING THAT
THE OPERATOR. I AND THE TEAMS SO
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I FIND YOUR
AND YOUR PROTECTING MY FAMILY'S
FARM TEAM. AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW
THE GREATER AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY SO IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING THAT. WE KNOW I MEAN I'VE
I'VE BEEN OUT OF TO OF WINERY
AND FRANCE WHEN A TRACTOR ROLLED
AND- AN OPERATOR WAS WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED SO THIS IS.
NOT A SAFE PLACE TO BE SO HOW DO
WE DO THAT SAFELY AND WE ARE ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY- WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT FARMING AGRICULTURAL
LANDSCAPES THIS ISN'T A FREEWAY.
OR OR THE CITY SO IT'S THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO REALLY
CONSIDERED HOW CAN WE GET
THROUGH THIS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE.
THIS PROGRESS FOR OUR
AGRICULTURAL. AND FOOD TO
SPEAKER SYSTEMS YEAH I KNOW A
COUPLE IMPORTANT POINTS THEIR
CARLO AND- THE REGULATIONS
WRITTEN BACK IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES ARE PRIMARILY AROUND
THE ARAB WORLD ADEQUATE. WHICH
IS ESSENTIALLY. THAT A ALONG
DITCH I TO STEER EFFECTIVELY ARE
HOWEVER SNAPPER. FARMERS FROM
ATOP THE MODERN DAY CITY
TECHNOLOGY ARE THAT PREVENTS
TRACTOR ROLLOVERS CHEMICAL
EXPOSURE. AND ALSO P. T. O. N.
IN SOME OF THE DANGEROUS. PART
OF OUR BEING ON. ARE AND THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS A VERY MUCH TOP TO
BE I'LL TALK. IN SERVICE THAT
CAN VISIONS SORRY IT'S THE INTEL
. OF THE PLATFORM IN THE MACHINE
BEING ABLE TO HOUSE FULL CONTROL
OF WHAT'S GOING ON THE MACHINE-
SO IT IS VERY MUCH COUPLE TO-
WHAT WE'RE DOING ON A LARGER
SCALE HERE. ARE MOTOR TRACTOR-
WE STARTED TO ENGAGE WITH CAL
OSHA BACK IN THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ARE IN ORDER TO.
EDUCATE THEM AND START TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE INTENTIONALLY
DEPLOY THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND IN
A SAFE WAY- WE'VE BEEN APPROVED
NOW FOR A TEMPORARY EXPERIMENT
VARIANTS TO DEPLOY. OUR THREE
TRACTORS AT TWO DIFFERENT SITES
IN CALIFORNIA- BUT IT'S ONLY.
FOR A SINGLE CROP TYPE AND
THERE'S A- YES. A LIMITATIONS
ARE STUCK ON TOP OF THAT- THE
CURRENT. A REGULAR AND- REQUIRE
. A VERY TO BE A LOT OF. TO
EVERY. FAR THAT WANTS TO. DEPLOY
THIS KIND OF. ARE AGAIN BECAUSE
OF THE AND- IN THE SYSTEM-
HOWEVER THE TECH. IS HERE I WILL
ARE NOT THE ONLY ONES. TO POINT
A TECHNOLOGY CALIFORNIA- AND WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE- TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS
WORK OUT AT A LARGER. THIS
QUESTIONS. RIGHT RIGHT. AND IF
LOVE THIS TECHNOLOGY- I'D LOVE
TO SEE A WORKING LIKE TO SEE
WHEN YOU'RE WHERE YOU HAVE IT-
BECAUSE LOOK AT THIS IS GREAT
FOR START SO NOT GOING TO BE
CRITICAL MISSING IN A GREAT.
GRAPE ORCHARD GOING FROM BY A
BIGGER. THANK THAT THEY WOULD BE
- AND SO THAT MAKES WILL BE THAN
SOME OTHER USES WHAT'S- HOURS
FOR USE ON A CHARGE ON A TRACTOR
YES SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT A TEN
HOURS OF TIME I REALLY DEPENDS A
LOT ON THE TO DOING SOMETHING
THAT'S GROUNDING IT'S GOING TO
BE CLOSER FOUR OR FIVE HOURS IF
IT JUST AROUND IN COLLECTING
WITH THE SAN. ARE YOU LOOKING
TWENTY HOURS OF RUNTIME ARE THE
CHORE TIME FOR SINGLE BAD ARE IS
ANY FROM FOUR TO FIVE HOUR-
AGAIN THERE'S ARE COMPLEX AROUND
WHAT THEY'RE WHAT GOING TO TRIP
LOOKS LIKE A THE FARM THINGS OF
THAT. HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME
BATTERY SYSTEM SO I DOES I
WRITTEN. RUN MARK STONE TEN
MINUTES BETWEEN THE YEAH HOLD ON
JUST SAY MY GUY I TALKED YARD WE
ALREADY HAVE ALL THE ELECTRICAL
THERE WE THIS WAS WE NEED. SO
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE- KIND A
STRUCTURE WE EASILY TRACK IN
THAT FOUR TO FIVE HOUR TIME
PERIOD ALSO THE BASED ON A ZERO
TO FULL WELL ALMOST NEVER TO TRY
TO THE ARTS ZERO BE LIKE 10% YOU
KNOW BY PER OF RIGHT DOWN YEAH.
YEAH WHAT'S A GOOD IT'S ABOUT
FOR- YOU PEOPLE TO GET A BECAUSE
AS WE STILL LIVE IN THE
WINTERTIME WE'RE USUALLY WORKING
ON OUR BOB BARR TRACKED IN OUR-
OUR QUICK MAY ENOUGH AND FIX
THEM. BUT THE SAME STUFF THAT
DOESN'T NOW YEAH SYSTEM WOULD DO
THIS. ONE NO QUESTIONS- YEAH I
MEAN JUST JUST ECHOING WITH THE
MEMBER JUST MENTIONED. IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT NEVER
GONNA NEED MORE TEACHERS MORE
MECHANICS THE QUESTION IS TO YOU
GUYS IS THAT DO YOU GUYS OFFER
THAT MECHANICAL HEALTH. YES SO
WE DO- ESSENTIALLY USERS TWO
SIDES OF THAT STORY ONE IS THAT
THE- COULDN'T ITSELF NEEDS A
LESS MAINTENANCE BECAUSE IT IS
ELECTRIFY A LOT LESS MOVING
PARTS- BUT YOU'RE STARTING TO
MOVE INTO KIND OF NEW AREAS THAT
MOST MECHANICS HAVEN'T SEEN.
BEFORE ANSWER LIKE THINGS LIKE
HIGH VOLTAGE OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEMS WE'VE DONE OUR BEST TO
MAKE THINGS MODULAR- SO SHIPPING
PARTS ARE ENABLING THE FARMERS
ARE FARMERS IN THE FARM
MECHANICS TO ACTUALLY PERFORM
THE MAINTENANCE THEMSELVES ARE
WE HAVE. OUR INSTRUCTIONS THAT
COME UP ON THE SCREEN AND ARE
AVAILABLE ON THE APP WE VERY
MUCH WANT TO ENABLE ARE KIND OF
THE- THE MECHANICS THEMSELVES
AND THEN THERE ARE SOME
TRAININGS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
DOING NOW IT'S A LITTLE EARLY
FOR KIND OF THE STAGE THAT WE'RE
AT. BUT. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WERE ACTIVELY ADDRESSING. YOU
SURE SOUNDS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
- THANK YOU BOTH GREAT
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND WE DON'T HAVE AYE YOU GUYS
TO COME AND SEE THE FACTORY AND
DOES IT- THE LAB AND EVERYTHING
AND SEE THE TRACTORS AND AN
ACTION. SO PLAN PERCENT WILL BE
THERE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE- MUNOZ SHOWMAN
. VICE PRESIDENT AND GENERAL
COUNSEL PACIFIC COAST PRODUCERS. NUMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHARITY OF THE DO A AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR INVITING
PACIFIC COAST PRODUCERS TO THIS
PANEL TODAY WE APPRECIATE BEING
INCLUDED- I HAVE TO SAY IT'S
KIND OF TOUGH TO BE THE LAST
SPEAKER ON THE PANEL WITH- ALL
THESE EXCELLENT SPEAKERS WHO
HAVE GONE BEFORE ME AND ALL THE
REALLY GOOD INFORMATION THAT
THEY'VE PROVIDED WHICH YOU KNOW
HAS SPEND- REALLY EXCELLENT
INFORMATION AND- I HAVE TO SAY.
A LOT OF WHAT HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
TODAY ARE THEMES THAT WE'RE
SEEING AS WELL AND SO YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO REPEAT A LOT OF
INFORMATION YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD- BUT- YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT ON FARM AGRICULTURE AND-
TECHNOLOGY. IN THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY I WANT TO SHIFT THE
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT NOW TO. THE
PROF FOOD PRODUCTION INDUSTRY-
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF PARALLELS
AND WHEN I'VE LISTENED TO THE
SPEAKERS TODAY THERE'S A LOT OF
CHANGE OCCURRING IN THE
INDUSTRY. AND THE TECHNOLOGY IS
CREATING CHANGE IN THE WORK
FORCE- THE AGING WORKFORCE IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHINGTHAT WE'RE
SEEING- CONNECTING THE ADEQUATE
EDUCATION TO THE LOCATION IN
WHICH OUR WORKERS- LIVE AND WORK
IS ALSO A CHALLENGE. AND- THE
SPEAKER MENTIONED THE ISSUE OF
SCALE BRINGING SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS TO SMALLER COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE'S- SMALLER PEOPLE
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO CONNECT THE
RESOURCES SO THAT. YOU CAN
PROVIDE PROGRAMS IN MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS SO THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF CHALLENGES TO WHAT WERE
FACING WITH OUR WORK FORCE- YOU
KNOW AGRICULTURE AND FRESH FOOD
IS AWESOME AND WE LOVE IT- BUT
THERE'S A DISCONNECT BETWEEN A
LOT OF FOR THE POPULATION LIVES
AND WHERE A LOT OF THE FOOD IS
GROWN SO. THE FOOD PRODUCTION
MANUFACTURING SIDE OF THE
EQUATION IS VERY IMPORTANT WE
PRESERVE FOOD- WE ARE NOT-
PROCESSED IN THE SENSE THAT
WE'RE A HIGHLY PROCESSED FOOD
WHAT WE DO AND OTHERS IN OUR
INDUSTRY. IS PRESERVED FOODS FOR
SHELF STABLE FOR DISTRIBUTION
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY ALL OVER
THE WORLD- CANNING FREEZING AND
DRYING OR ALL MINIMALLY
PROCESSED AND PRESERVE- THE
HEALTHY NATURE OF THE FOOD
THAT'S GROWN. OUR COMPANY
PACIFIC COAST PRODUCERS IS A
GROWER OWNED AGRICULTURAL
COOPERATIVE OUR GROWERS GROW UP
PEACHES PEARS TOMATOES APER
CARTS AND GRAPES. AND ARE A
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THREE PRODUCTION PLANTS- ONE UP
IN ORVILLE ABOUT TWO HOURS NORTH
OF HERE. ONE IN THE WOODLAND
AREA AND SENATOR FOR US USE ME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AGUILAR CRUZ
AREA AND- LODI WHERE A ASSEMBLY
MAN COOPER REPRESENTS US AND-
THIS REVIEW HAS BEEN TO OUR- OUR
LOCATIONS AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH. WE CURRENTLY-
EMPLOYED ABOUT A THOUSAND FULL
TIME YEAR ROUND EMPLOYEES AND
ABOUT. THREE THOUSAND TO THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED SEASONAL EMPLOYEES
. OUR FACILITIES ARE ALL IN
CENTRAL VALLEY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CULTURALLY
AND ETHNICALLY DIVERSE IN OUR
WORK FORCE IS ABOUT 60% LATINO
AND ABOUT 30% EAST INDIAN AND
AFGHANI. OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
PRIMARILY LOCAL TO THEIR
COMMUNITY AND ARE SEASONAL
WORKERS STAY ON THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND DO A VARIETY OF
JOBS IN THE OFF SEASON SO IT'S A
VERY STABLE WORK FORCE. OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE REPRESENTED BY THE
TEAMSTERS CANNERY COUNCIL AND I
WERE OR SPECIALLY MADE MASKS
TODAY WHICH HAS THE TEAMSTERS
LOGO AND OTHER PRODUCERS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
OUR MULTI EMPLOYER BARGAINING
GROUP WE'VE ENJOYED A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE-
TEAMSTERS OVER MANY DECADES IT'S
NOT ALWAYS WITHOUT CONTENTION OF
COURSE BUT- YOU KNOW WE WORK
WITH THEM VERY WELL. I DID WANT
TO MENTION A COUPLE PROGRAMS
THAT WE APPRECIATE THAT'S OUR US
UNRELATED TO NECESSARILY THE
WORK FORCE BUT OUR GROWERS
ENJOYED THE SWEEP PROGRAM THE
STATE WATER EFFICIENCY
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM. AND THE
FARMER PROGRAM WHICH IS A
PROGRAM THAT. HELPS AG REPLACE
ADEQUATE WENT THROUGH CARB AS
WELL AS THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM. NOW WE DON'T DIRECTLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE FARMING OF
OUR CROPS THE WE TAKE DELIVERY
OF THE CROPS AT OUR FACILITIES-
BUT ONE PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN
HELPFUL FOR US AT PACIFIC COAST
PRODUCERS HAS BEEN THE FOOD
PROCESS. FOOD PROCESSOR
INVESTMENT PROGRAM THIS WAS A
PROGRAM THAT WAS CREATED WITH
FUNDS FROM THE- GREENHOUSE GAS
PROGRAM. UNDER THAT IS A GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP US PUT ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND MORE SOPHISTICATED
EQUIPMENT AND TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE ASES AND OUR
FACILITIES. WE'VE HAD- SEVERAL
PROJECTS AND PUT IN- HIGHEST
HIGH EFFICIENCY EVAPORATOR-
UPGRADED TO MADE A HT BREAKS-
IN THE- TOMATO PASTE PRODUCTION
AS WELL AS ENERGY EFFICIENT
REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS AND THAT'S
BEEN VERY APPRECIATED AND VERY
HELPFUL IN US BECOMING. MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENT AND REDUCING
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS- YEAH- OUR
FOOD- FOOD PRODUCTION IN THE
PAST HAS BEEN HIGHLY MANUAL AT
OUR FACILITIES RUN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
ONCE THE HARVEST BEGINS UNTIL
THE HARVEST ENDS. IN THE
OFFSEASON ARE FULL TIME WORK
FORCE CONDUCTS MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR- AND- CONDUCTS CAPITAL
PROJECTS TO IMPROVE THE
FACILITIES AND AT OUR LOAD I
PLANT THE- DECORATE A FORKLIFT A
GIANT FORKLIFT INTO A HOLIDAY
TRAIN THAT PARTICIPATES IN THE
LOCAL FOR A- PARADE OF LIGHTS.
WHICH IS TOMORROW BY THE WAY- SO
IN RECENT DECADES WE HAVE
AUTOMATED AND- INCREASE
TECHNOLOGY ON OUR PLANS IN ORDER
TO INCREASE EFFICIENCIES BUT
ALSO TO MAKE OUR JOBS A LITTLE
BIT EASIER I THINK THERE'S BEEN
A THEME HERE THAT A LOT OF THE
LOW PAY ON HARD WORK WAS ALSO
REFLECTED IN THE PROCESSING
FACILITIES IN THE PAST AND THAT
IS CHANGING. ALONG WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF THE AGING
WORKFORCE AND THE LACK OF STAFF
HAS ACCELERATED THIS PROCESS IN
RECENT TIMES NO I DID PROVIDE-
SOME SLIDES FOR YOU AND I WON'T
GO THROUGH EACH ONE OF THEM BUT
I DID WANT TO MAKE COMMENTS ON A
FEW OF THEM THE FIRST FLIGHT IS
OUR HIGH PRESSURE STEAM BOILER
WE PUT THAT IN OUR WOODLAND
PLANT- TWO YEARS AGO. AND THAT'S
PROBABLY THE MOST STATE OF THE
ART BOILER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S- VERY ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND THE PROTECT THE
PEOPLE WHO OPERATE THOSE BOILERS
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE MORE HMI
HUMAN MACHINE INTERFACE WORKING
WITH SCREENS WORKING WITH DATA
THE AIR QUALITY REGULATIONS OF
COURSE BECOME MORE DETAILED AND
SO WE NEED TO EDUCATE OUR BOILER
OPERATORS TO BE MORE
SOPHISTICATED- THE NEXT SLIDE IS
THE OPTICAL SORTING TECHNOLOGY.
SO IN THE PAST THIS WOULD HAVE
BEEN A BELT WITH PEOPLE ALONG
SIDE THE BUILT RESORT MANUALLY
SORTING THANK YOU AWESOME AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE NEXT PAGE IT
SHOWS YOU WITH THE- PROGRESSION
OF THE TECHNOLOGY WHERE THE
CAMERAS CAN SEE AS WELL AS THE
HUMAN EYE AND THOUGH FRUITS GOES
THROUGH THE MACHINES VERY
QUICKLY ON THEM THE MACHINE
IDENTIFIES A BLEMISHED FRUIT
AND- PUFFS AIR. THAT THE FRUIT
TO KNOCK IT DOWN BELOW THE BELT
THAT'S GOING ON INTO THE
PROCESSING IT'S REALLY A QUITE
INTERESTING. AND FASCINATING
TECHNOLOGY- THE NEXT PAGE THAT
SEE ON THE AUTOMATED TOMATO FLOW
. THERE'S GENERALLY PEOPLE
OPERATING ALL OF THESE POINTS
OF- TRANSFERENCE WHERE THE
TOMATOES COME INTO THE PLANTS
ARE TRANSFERRED BY FLAMES AND
RINSED AND GO UP THE ELEVATORS
INTO THE PLANTS THIS WILL ALL BE
AUTOMATED AND SO. HAS SOME OF
THE DISCUSSION YOU'VE HEARD
BEFORE ABOUT THE AUTO REMOTE
OPERATING GATES AND REMOTE
MONITORING OF QUALITY AND THINGS
LIKE THAT IS WHERE WE'RE HEADED
WITH OUR PLANTS AS WELL. THE
NEXT PICTURE THE PL SEASON
OUTPUT DISPLAYS IS JUST TO SHOW
YOU WHAT THE THIS CHANGES IN OUR
PLANTS WE HAVE NOW YOU KNOW
HIGHLY AUTOMATED DIGITAL READ
OUT SO THAT. ULTIMATELY WE WOULD
LIKE TO GET TO A LIVE REAL TIME-
READ OF THE PRODUCT GOING
THROUGH OUR PLANS AT THE MOMENT
SO THAT YOU CAN MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
BASED ON THE QUALITY OF THE
PRODUCT AT THE TIME SO THAT WILL
MAKE US MORE EFFICIENT AND
AGAIN. IT JUST INCREASES THE
NEED FOR PEOPLE WHO CAN WORK
WITH THESE TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES- THERE'S MORE
SLIDES ABOUT OUR OUR CASE
STACKING ROBOTICS WHICH MAKES
THE WORK LESS MANUAL FOR PEOPLE
WHICH IS A GOOD THING IT'S HARD
WORK. OR PALLETIZER AUTOMATION.
AND OUR CANS STACKING ALL OF
THESE- REQUIRE. PEOPLE WHO CAN
SERVICE THESE MACHINES SO WHEN
YOU EARLIER ASKED ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY ELIMINATING SOME JOBS
I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THEY
PROBABLY WILL ELIMINATE SOME
JOBS IT'LL ELIMINATE MAYBE THOSE
SORTING JOBS OR THE SANITATION
JOBS WHERE YOU'RE THERE WITH THE
HIGH PRESSURE WAND. CLEANING
EQUIPMENT BUT WHAT IT WILL
CHANGE THAT TO IS YOU NEED THE
PEOPLE TO MAINTAIN THE EQUIPMENT
YOU NEED PEOPLE TO PROGRAM THE
CONTROLS TO READ THE CONTROLS TO
MAKE UP THE APPROPRIATE
DECISIONS OFF OF THE DATA THAT
THEY GET FROM THAT TECHNOLOGY IN
ORDER TO RUN THE OPERATIONS. SO
CAN I JUST INTERRUPT YOU YES OF
COURSE I MEAN. IT WILL HOW DO
YOU RECRUIT WE'RE WORRIED
GETTING YOUR LABOR FORCE FOR
THIS. SO CURRENTLY WE HAVE IT'S
A CHALLENGE SO WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF WAYS OF RECRUITING WE-
pOF OUT OF STATE- ENTITIES
THERE'S A PERRY TECHNICAL
INSTITUTE UP IN YAKIMA
WASHINGTON THAT HAS A- STE-
INSTITUTE THAT SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED TOWARDS CONTROLS TAX AN
INSTRUMENT TAX. AND YOU GO TO
THEIR JOB FAIRS AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY NATIONAL EMPLOYERS THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR THE SAME THING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR I WAS
VERY ENCOURAGED TODAY TO HEAR
THE GENTLEMAN FROM HARTNELL
COLLEGE AND- MAYBE TALKING TO
HIM AFTERWARDS BECAUSE I WAS
VERY INTERESTED IN HIS PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
STATE HELPS SUPPORT THE EXPORT
OF THOSE TYPES OF PROGRAMS TO
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S TRUE THAT PEOPLE IN
OUR INDUSTRY LIKE TO STAY WHERE
THEY ARE AND SO WE NEED TO GET
THE EDUCATION TO THEM SO THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THERE'S GOOD JOBS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. THAT THEY
CAN HAVE- YOU KNOW WELL PAYING
JOBS WITH BENEFITS THAT THEY CAN
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY ON AND THEY
CAN STAY WHERE THEY ARE SO YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT'S- THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL WE ALSO YOU KNOW DO WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE DOES AND PUT JOBS
ON INDEED AND MONSTER AND ALL
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS- SO- IT.
IT'S A CHALLENGE IT'S A
CHALLENGE TO RECRUIT. THANK YOU
FOR THESE TYPES OF AND AGAIN I
THINK IT'S BEEN SAID EARLIER AG.
AND FOOD PROCESSING IS NOT
NECESSARILY A DESIRED CAREER-
PEOPLE WANT TO GO WORK FOR
GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK AND THINGS
LIKE THAT SO WE NEED TO MAKE
OUR- JOB OPPORTUNITIES. MORE
MARKETED TO PEOPLE SO THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES. AND WE DO A GOOD
THING WE FEED THE NATION WE FEED
THE WORLD IT'S NOT- IT'S NOT A
NEGATIVE TO BE IN THE FOOD
PROCESSING INDUSTRY- SO AS FAR
AS YOU KNOW LOOKING FORWARD. AS
TO WHAT TO DO NOW WE'VE
PARTICIPATED IN SOME LOCAL
PROGRAMS ARE LOCAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HAD A PROGRAM WHERE WE
TRIED TO GET OUR MECHANICS AND
OUR ELECTRICIANS TO GO TO THE
SCHOOLS TO THE HIGH SCHOOLS AND
TALK TO THE- STUDENTS THERE
ABOUT HEY YOU KNOW YOU CAN GO TO
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE GET AN
EDUCATION AND HAVE A GOOD JOB
HERE. AND THAT'S- BEEN SOMEWHAT
SUCCESSFUL BUT AGAIN IT'S A
QUESTION OF SCALE- AND IT'S A
QUESTION OF RESOURCES TO DO
THAT- THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION WELL I'M- SURE YOU
PROBABLY ARE WELL FAMILIAR WITH
DID A REPORT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TALKING ABOUT- THE AUTOMATED
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND ITS
IMPACT ON THE WORK FORCE. AND IN
THAT REPORT THEY READ MADE
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS AND A
COUPLE I FELT WERE RELEVANT TO
THE ISSUE TODAY AND ONE OF THOSE
WAS THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
IMPLEMENT CHANGES TO IMPROVE ITS
DATA COLLECTION ON JOBS AND
SKILLS FOR FUTURE WORKERS SO
THAT A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WORKFORCE AND EMPLOYMENT NEEDS
TRANSISTORIZED AND PLANNING. FOR
EXAMPLE THE HOOVER COMMISSION
REFERRED TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE FOR LABOR MARKET
RESEARCH THE CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE CONDUCTS SPECIAL
PROJECTS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE NEEDS OF THE WORKFORCE IN
EVOLVING AND EMERGING INDUSTRIES
BY CONDUCTING POINT IN TIME
SURVEYS AND TALKING TO EMPLOYERS
AND CONTROLLED WAYS THE CENTER
OF EXCELLENCE HAS ACCURATE REAL
TIME INFORMATION ON JOB TRENDS.
SO THAT WOULD BE AN EXISTING
RESOURCE THAT COULD BE UTILIZED
TO HELP PLAN FOR HOW TO HOW TO
EXPEND RESOURCES AND TARGET
RESOURCES TOWARDS IMPROVING OUR
OUR WORK- APPRENTICESHIPS AND
OTHER TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
SHOULD BE PROMOTED BY CALIFORNIA
FOR PRIVATE INDUSTRIES WHERE
JOBS ARE DISPLACED BY
TECHNOLOGY- TAX CREDITS HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED AS A TOOL TO DO
THAT- FINALLY THE HOOVER
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED THE STATE
PARTNER WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS- WHICH PROVIDE
TOOLS FOR JOB SEARCHES AND
ONLINE. A LEARNING WHICH AGAIN
WAS SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CONTEXT
WHICH- WOULD BE IN OUR VIEW A
VERY POSITIVE THING. SO YOU KNOW
IN SHORT I THINK THIS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED ALSO THE STATE'S RIGHT
NOW SEEMS TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A SURPLUS AND WE WOULD LOVE
TO SEE PART OF THAT SURPLUS GO.
TOWARDS ENCOURAGING AND FUNDING
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS IT SOUNDS
LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE IN PROCESS AND A LOT OF
GOOD IDEAS AND I THINK IT'S JUST
BRINGING THEM TOGETHER AND
COORDINATING AND PROVIDING SOME
FUNDING. FOR THE GOOD PROGRAMS
THAT WILL HELP PEOPLE THAT WOULD
BE THAT WOULD BE VERY
ADVANTAGEOUS AND AS AN EMPLOYER
YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY STAND
WILLING TO PARTICIPATE IN
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT. FROM BEING
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
WHAT ARE THE PRIORITY FOR THE-
FIGURING UP WITH- WHAT KIND YOU
WERE READING THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. POPPIES HERE SAVE ON. THE LAST LITTLE WHILE AND I
LOVE THE ANIMATION OR THE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU WE'VE YOUR
SUPPORT. I HAVE A- YOU MEANT
THERE WAS A- THAT WOULD. UPDATE
THE WORK FOR DATA. I WOULD YOUR
ON ALL THIS OPINION ON UPDATING
OUR REGULATIONS. UPDATING
REGULATIONS- WELL WITH RESPECT
TO- TECHNOLOGY IN THE WORK
FORCE- YOU KNOW I DON'TSEE
REGULATIONS AS A BURDEN IN THAT
RESPECT I THINK IT'S REALLY
PUTTING TOGETHER PROGRAMS TO
HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
CONNECT THEM WITH WITH THE
EMPLOYERS. I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS HERE- MICHELIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. OKAY.
YEAH. WE WILL NOW BEGIN OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO INVITE
THOSE IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
COME COME UP FIRST AND THEN WE
WILL GO TO THOSE ON THE PHONE.
REMEMBER THAT I'M ALLOWING ONLY
ONE MINUTE PER PERSON FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. PRICE. FIFTEEN NINE-
AGAIN NOW WILL GO TO PUBLIC-
PUBLIC TOLL FREE OUR PUBLIC TOLL
FREE NUMBER FOR THE HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO-
WESTERN MODERATOR IF THERE'S
ANYONE ONLINE. AT A TIME THERE'S
NO WINNING Q. THERE'S NO ONE IN
ON THE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THEN I WILL MOVE TO FINAL
COMMENTS AND I WILL ASK- EITHER
OUR MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
FINAL COMMENT. I SEEN IT THANK
YOU FOR C. NINE. K. CLOSING
REMARKS I WANT TO CLOSE BY READ
RESTATING THE AGRICULTURE
CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA AND AS WELL AS WE
HAVE LEARNED HERE TODAY HAVE
BEEN A TRAINED WORKFORCE IN AG
TECHNOLOGY WILL PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN KEEPING CALIFORNIA. AT
THE FOREFRONT OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION. AGTECH ANALOGY MAY
NOT HELP US SOLVE ALL OF OUR
PROBLEMS BUT IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP JUMPSTART NEW
INNOVATION THAT CAN IMPROVE. OUR
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR INCREASE OUR
FOOD SECURITY AND IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR AGRICULTURE
FARMERS AND WORKERS. THERE ARE
MANY CHALLENGES AS WE WE'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH EVERYONE
HERE TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
INCREASE OUR AG TECHNOLOGY
WORKFORCE. AND ALSO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A GLOBAL LEADER IN
AGTECH SECTOR. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS TODAY
PROVIDING VALUABLE INFORMATION
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE
AND ON HOW THE STATE CAN
PREPARE. CALIFORNIA FUTURE
AGRICULTURE AGTECH WORKFORCE AND
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
OVERALL. BEFORE A GERMAN DESCENT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TODAY I
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE AGAIN
WHO'S WATCHING OR WATCHING OR
LISTENING. TO THIS HEARING THAT
THROUGHOUT THIS COMING YEAR THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE HAVING A
SERIES OF FOLLOW UP HEARINGS
WHERE WE- DRIVE DEEPER INTO SOME
OF THE TOPICS THAT WE HEARD HERE
TODAY INCLUDING EDUCATIONAL.
TRAINING AUTOMATION AND OTHER
TOPICS. WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE AND WE'LL DURING
THIS MEETING THANK EVERYONE.